pulled up to calabasas ready for where i
might turn to a savage i just showed up
with the crewy the baddest you just
showed up like you might need some
practice uh you going down for the count
it's going down tonight i do it all for
my family you do it all for the likes i
hit that bell and i'm ready to fight
turn me up turn me up turn me up they
want the belt they don't work and know
don't mess around and i'm hurting them i
say the wrong thing make it personal
[Music]
[Applause]
you beautiful people i know you're
expecting to see your boy brendan child
but not today young bucks he's out in
the world on tour and so you got old
matron out here causing a ruckus but i
brought two of my best good buddies with
you with me
my to my left is my best good buddy some
people call my mma daddy rashad
sweet sugar rashad evans and then to my
right i got joseph stitch's ass up
shilling the most beautiful cats in the
world
what does that mean stitches ass up
let's talk about it
you're still stitching them up there
tell them about it what's it from joe uh
my
i was a muay thai fighter for a long
time and um
my first like seven fights everybody got
my first seven pro fights everybody got
stitches i had my count was like uh
over 100 stitches and and fights by my
seventh or eighth pro fight so i think i
was like
stitch them up stitch them up chilling i
like it how it's gonna go
probably the best ring game there is
i'll be honest we're gonna talk about
ring names i got i like touchy-feely
andre touchy-feely
i think that's a hell of a nickname man
i think that's really funny that's funny
as hell
do you remember there was a dude that
fought a long time ago oh not a long
time ago probably what eight nine years
ago and his name was bread awesomeness
and he went by brad awesomely awesome
awesomeness and i was like you can't do
that man that's a little too much man
never heard that he fought in the ufc
yeah fought in ufc look him up
brad awesomeness or something like that
and he went by awesomely awesome
awesomeness or something like that
i don't know if i would qualify that one
that's the best ring name but i'm just
saying it's stuck out just a damn funny
ring name though i'll stick with stitch
them up but then
or stephen stitch his hand he's never
had one
no never no no i like i like meathead
meat yeah meat meathead i think
what happened you know what kind of
throws me off man is that my kids don't
get called me dead like how is that
possible how i've been called meathead
my entire life and my kids are like i
said hey do you all get called meat
meathead meat lip sweet meat meat feet
anything at all and they're like
nah man
it's the energy though
it's the energy they don't embody the
energy it might be that yeah it's meat
headaches
i remember being i remember being on
tough
and um
i was a a complete like i didn't know
anything about the sport i'd literally
been training for like six months seven
months and i knew nothing about it and i
came out to rashad and i was like
i was like hey like um
dude i was like i don't know anything
about wrestling i need to know and i
know you're a wrestler can you please
select me i want to be on your team you
remember that
and i was like um and he was like yeah i
think like
they had never fought ever like i had no
fights and he was like ah okay and he
picked me on like fifth or sixth or
something like that and like we had it
was it was interesting man that was the
the ultimate fighter was a really
interesting experience like
i would do it again but not for less
than half a ticket like i yeah i need to
get paid a lot of money to do that
because you now know the mental part of
it that was hard i mean you i've seen
people on that show
forget even why they even go on the show
you know what i'm saying they get to the
point where they get so caught up in
what's going on and they forget about
their life on the outside and then life
on the outside is just calling them and
pulling them and they'll do anything
do anything to get to their own life you
know what i'm saying they even quit
fighting they'd be like you know what
this fighting ain't for me and i watch
people talk themselves out of being on
the show
i mean it's it's wild man and it's a
it's the most amazing
um
it's the most amazing
real life example
of uh
of uh
lord of the flies like it's a living
embodiment of it because you're given a
beautiful environment right some big ass
mansion in vegas
you're giving any kind of food you want
whenever you want to get any type of
liquor you have you can run the roost
rule the roost in any which way you want
and it's just a matter of time until
the place starts to dissolve itself or
you start to dissolve the place like you
can't just be
happy in a utopian environment there's
always some jockeying for position you
have alphas you have you have betas you
have cucks you have pseudo alphas i
think they're really the man but they're
not until they finally come across the
man and some people are just so chill
they don't really care about it but it's
amazing how the entire environment
collapses on itself and it happens every
single season happens all the time yeah
it's funny it's funny to see how that
dynamic worked through i forgot even
about it until you're just talking about
it that aspect where you know everybody
asserts who's the alpha male you know
what i'm saying and it's like
usually like a subtle kind of
acknowledgement like okay that's the
[ __ ] everybody gotta watch out
you know what i'm saying that's the dude
and uh on my season it was mike
whitehead oh yeah he was that dude he
was that dude so when i had to fight
mike whitehead they were like man rashad
you did really good thus far man you
gave it a go there
and i was like man i'm gonna beat mike
whitehead's ass yeah when did you fight
him in the finale or what was it i
fought him in the quarters yeah how many
times did you fight on the show uh three
times really yeah and then three times
and then the finale then the finale yeah
yeah four times all together so you
fought him you fought him in the show
and then you uh
obviously you won you want you
would you guys want to go two rounds
also would you guys go three no we went
three rounds so that's why so our season
is the only season where they counted
the records because they had to get this
round to fight sanction because they
went three rounds
see this is when they're still figuring
out what season were you season two okay
so it was after the first season and
they're kind of still figuring out like
what the formula is going to be so my
season was they trying out the three
rounds but they did it with heavyweights
which is probably a bad idea and you
know saying they had three rounds of
just [ __ ]
and that was before like heavyweights
truly like met like changed to what
happened
right
it's wild like you just said that man
you've been you've been through
an evolution of the sport you've
actually been through two evolutions at
this point yeah um that's really
interesting man like where you going up
in weight wasn't really it was it was
like you were small but it wasn't that
much of a stretch because you had such a
skill set and nowadays it's like like
some people wanted to fight up people
didn't really ever want to fight their
weight and people try to cut try to get
like much smaller and now it's like it's
people can really like they're at a spot
where they can do pretty much whatever
the hell they want to do because the
skill set's grown so much yeah
man when i see these guys now that
competes just just how fluid they are
going from one transition to the next
you know one technique to the next you
know and they do it so seamlessly and
that's the mark of a true martial artist
you know because it it it goes beyond
the whole thinking aspect you know we
train to just react right and when you
see these guys out there just flowing
and going and hitting these transitions
you're like damn the game has changed so
much i mean there usually time where you
gotta be like do a punch and then you do
that little bounce and then you do the
shot you know what i'm saying and it
would still land
it was still let him drive the guy
across the cage with that little crazy
shot but
things have changed so much my guys are
just they flew it they're smooth man
it's just gonna keep going too like now
like the
you know before back in the day
obviously there was like you were one or
the other and then you transitioned to
the other you know you were a striker
and then you learned the wrestling or
whatever but now like the kids that are
doing this now are going to be insane
well dude they start from the job
they're like from their first day
they're doing everything right yeah like
for me i was a one-trick pony right i
was a st i was a knockout artist i was a
stand-up guy i couldn't wrestle i
couldn't really grapple i couldn't get
back to my feet too well i was like a
damn turtle if you got me on the ground
i was gonna be in a whole world of
trouble uh and i tried i got worked i
wrestled i tried to do everything i
could i just never developed as much as
i should have probably didn't care as
much as i probably should have to
develop a whole lot more um but is that
how you felt like coming into mma were
you like dude i'm like i'm going to try
to do everything i can here but i'm i
[ __ ] throw it that's what i do yeah
well
it was so different from kickboxing you
know with kickboxing i'm just i'm going
like we were talking about earlier just
i'm just reacting and fighting you know
and then with mma it was like oh my god
he's going to grab me and then it
doesn't matter how good a striker you
are the thought of him taking you down
and the fear of that makes you not a
good striker and you start getting
caught by guys that should have no
business with the striker and i won't
even open up because i'm so worried
about it yeah and then what happens you
end up clenching and the exact same
thing happens that you're afraid of you
know yeah i mean so many times i've had
gotten out of the way
why didn't i go about it like you see a
lot of people they try to train and try
to worry about what somebody do you know
what they do specifically their special
move but when you do that like when you
start to
work around you know what your opponent
does you start to have like paralysis by
analysis what i'm saying you see that
[ __ ] the whole fight you see it
the whole fight like oh he's doing it
again and you just don't go but you see
it every you see it the whole fight you
know uh i mean that's how it was when i
fought machida like i was i was training
to to like
to do what he does and watch what he
does and everything like that and i shut
my own game out you know when he flash
knocked me down in the first round i'm
just like this disrespectful
[ __ ] he must not know i'm the
champ you know what i'm saying so then i
tried even harder and then you know like
when you try even harder things get
worse yeah you know what i'm saying so
that's yeah trying to force everything
so but but it was all because you know
what i'm saying i didn't do
i didn't do me i started getting into
you know watching out for this watching
out for that so like when i get guys i'm
like yo look this is what he do does
good but let's let's focus on you
because you can spend a whole camp
worrying about what somebody else does
and shut your whole [ __ ] down shut your
whole [ __ ] down i felt that
when i came from the nfl
i was brainwashed and watching film i
watched film all the damn time like in
fighting i'm sorry in football college
nfl all you do like you literally have
six hours a day of watching film um and
when i came over i started watching a
bunch of film all the time
and then i found myself
like literally
like i couldn't i was waiting for the
triggers and i couldn't do it anymore so
i had to stop watching film i had to
stop watching it and then eventually i
just stopped watching fights overall
it's like i don't i can't enjoy it and
i'm surrounded by it all the time i was
like and i'm my i felt like my life when
i switched over to fighting i felt like
my life got consumed by violence and i
couldn't find an escape and so the
easiest thing i could do was literally
leave it at work that's it and when i
got home when i i could be a fighter all
the way until my driveway and as soon as
i got in my driveway i had to leave
alone so i didn't watch it anymore i
didn't do anything because i felt like
it consumed me and i feel like i started
to become a different person and i
didn't like that
i could see that yeah i used to always
like that feeling though really oh my
god i used to love thinking about
fighting really yeah i used to love it
like i used to like to uh
like i mean it's
it was it was fun for me i didn't really
see it i didn't really associate it with
violence like it was never
violence to me
it i never felt like it was a chess
match it was just a physical adjustment
it's like
it's like i tell my my kids when they
watch me when they first watch me the
first time i'm just like
they would get scared i'm like no no
look
daddy's just playing with his friends
but we play like really rough that's it
we just play really rough you know and
i'm just thinking like i'm just playing
with my homie we just we just go on you
know we're playing a harder game a
really hard game but i don't really i
don't really think like
like oh you know this is the violent
[ __ ] you know even if i'm doing being
violent i still don't feel like it i
always looked at it like a challenge
like it was always like me versus him
and then that would like build that up
into my head like i'm not gonna let this
[ __ ] take this yeah yeah [ __ ]
this dude you know it was never like a
violent thing and then like as the fight
progressed where i see other people get
nervous and scared and have all those
emotions i get like really mad so for
like a long time
everybody that
saw me from the outside didn't know me
person was like man joe's an [ __ ]
he's always so [ __ ] pissed off he
looks so mad but that was my reaction to
that situation as i would get like like
me versus you [ __ ] yeah and
like i haven't fought in a while that's
what i miss most it's like that me
versus you but like the actual
uh training and the other stuff i don't
really enjoy it but i really love that
like me versus you like the challenge
aspect of it that's what gets me up has
always got me up
yeah i'm kind of i like that feeling but
i'm scared of it at the same time but i
love it though is that
that's the drug right there that feeling
where you're like
so afraid but at the same time you're so
excited
at the same time you're so hopeful you
have so many souls just like just
popping off and just like there's just a
roller coaster there's like so many of
them just going off inside of you you're
just like oh [ __ ] like
how do i tame this [ __ ] how do i tame
this beast inside of me how do i tame
this this emotional uh force that i'm
feeling right now without just
without cracking without you know
just holding it together so i can go out
there and compete you know that's the
fun part for me but
it's hard though because that eight
hours before you fight you're just like
oh it's like purgatory he's like [ __ ]
was the night before difficult for you
nah the night before it's cool like you
just like like tomorrow would never come
but then you wake up and you're just
like
oh
it's here
like oh
you feel it you're like oh
it's fight day he's like you just feel
it never sleep the night before
this happens i'm gonna do this and what
if this happens like all of those
scenarios are just playing through my
head of like a million different ways
and it can be freaking exhausting yeah
did y'all have superstitions like fight
day superstitions
willing to disclose almost every fight
i've ever had i've always got in the
ring having to pee it's like as soon as
my hands got wrapped and i put well
pick boxing gloves right so once they
tape those gloves on it's like [ __ ] i
gotta pee and like i'm not gonna ask my
coach to go hold it for me right but
like i always walked out to the ring
like i gotta be and i was like and then
it began as i got older in my career i
was like all right this is normal you
know this is all right yeah gotta pee
we're good here we go you know if you
didn't pee you're like oh [ __ ] yeah why
don't the pizza go wrong
i always before i fight i always take
like a really long shower and just like
really groom and manicure myself before
i fight really always it's at the hotel
yeah just in it and it just it calms me
down because like when i groom myself
like that i feel fly i feel good and
like when i feel good like that when i
look in the mirror and i'm just like
i feel good you know what i'm saying
then i was like oh i'm about the body's
about to get smashed you know then i
feel good about myself it starts working
on the energy and then it helps like
that that
that character that sugar to come out
you know that that one that's like
trying to embarrass somebody out there
for even signing the contract to fight
me you know yeah like that character
started to come out more and more the
more i started to like you know groom
myself and try to look pretty you know
but it keeps my mind off of
off of the fight you know because it's
like
i know for at least an hour and a half
my mind is gonna be focused on just
grooming myself getting ready and i'm
not thinking about what's gonna happen
with the whole fight you know so that's
why i like that routine
attention i think i have
like just not not about fighting
fighting i never i never got anxious
about the only the only time i ever got
anxious
when was when i fought roy nelson the
second time
uh i fought him in bellator
and i was anxious because
i was like dude
i'm gonna he's slow i'm gonna get off on
him
but he's gonna be there for 15 minutes
he is going to be there like it doesn't
matter what i can hit him with a goddamn
chevy it doesn't matter he's going to be
there and it was like the thought to me
of okay listen you're going to you have
to stick a move but you don't move too
much because as soon as you start moving
that's you're letting your feet sound
but that's a whole lot of movement for
15 minutes
and i was like that's a lot of goal like
there's not rest i'm not going to
wrestle them i don't want them to touch
me yeah and so like i had anxiety before
that one and it was like
anxiety but yeah and it really it wasn't
like it wasn't like i'm worried i'm
gonna get slapped by him because i
didn't think he was gonna touch me i was
worried about the energy level i was
gonna have to do it to whoop his ass
that's what i like i get it yeah i get
it man i get it but that's that's the
fun part about it for me
that is the fight the fight is not with
the guy
across the across the cage for me it's
with me it's with me dealing with that
that part of me that part of me that
want to [ __ ] out you know what i'm
saying the part of me that wants to be
that says like why am i here and then
the other apartment says [ __ ]
you know why you here because you're
sick this is what you like this is your
medicine right this makes you feel
better you know what i'm saying
that inner voice is yeah
just going back and forth man i love it
dude
i do you think that a lot of us have
that like are we sick yes are we
addicted to like are we addicted to
being addicted is that what we are no i
think there's something
there's something not wrong with us but
there's something different about it you
know i'm saying like there's something
that
that that's in us that um
it's just not normal you know and uh to
to be able to do what we got to do it's
just not
this is different you know what i'm
saying but even like the three of us is
different like as we're having this
conversation each one of us has like a
different thing that's wrong with us
it's not the same
hey so this is the fight that got bumped
up right this got bumped up because
cowboy okay
okay so they the whole fight got yanked
yep so joe lazar's not getting out nope
scratching what a bad deal for jill
lazan oh well i'm sure that dana dana
probably had to pay him his show and his
win
and his win yeah i bet he paid joe is
showing his win and probably cowboy
justice show if he did at all well sure
he went in what happened cowboy had
something happened to him cowboy cowboy
got sick after yeah today and pulled out
of the fight oh he got sick this is like
two hours ago oh man
oh
damn me
well you know what what's really dope is
that this is this is their time to shine
buddy yeah who's going to put on a make
out of a huge huge card
this is this is your time to go this is
the time to show out man i remember the
first time i got on a main card
matt hughes ufc 65. oh my gosh i was
just like
they're going to see me on the maze
i was just i
bugged out so i know he's got to be
going crazy right now for sure
joe did you feel that um
did you feel pressure or kind of stress
is that joel's on right there in the
background right there with his ears
yeah you know you can't miss that you
know that just got paid he's so happy
yeah look at that hey um but imagine how
good he feels oh
some brazilian dude ronnie marks i was
supposed to run i stepped in on like two
weeks notice uh for josh barnett and and
i stepped in and i had been working on
my house for like nine months i was just
building my house i didn't have anything
going on wasn't training didn't drive to
practice i literally had not been in the
gym at all but i was building my house i
needed some cash and they were like hey
you've got two weeks will you say yes to
this i was like yeah sure why not so i
get in there and i'm sitting there like
the day of and i'm like hey man like i'm
not really that good to show you this is
kind of it's gonna be a little bit of
tough of a goal like i gotta knock his
ass out quick you know he's a grappling
wrestler so i know he's gonna try to
shoot on me and [ __ ]
and then i get a call
like we have to report like nine o'clock
right yeah so i get to recall like 6 30
hey the whole fight's been called off
what are you talking about covet they
shut the whole entire thing down i was
like
thank you
and i was like that's the best thing
bellator could have done was cancel that
fight
but thanks for waiting after we weighed
in though appreciate it oh it was after
the win
it was day up thanks bro oh man and i
was flat purse i wouldn't show and win
hey that's that's that's g right there
oh my god i was able to come back home
and pay my bill there's a day ago is the
rest of it don't talk i mean listen
don't get me wrong i love to fight but i
mean if i could make money and not fight
yeah dude
i think you know what's even funny about
that
i was so worried about um i was worried
about kovalev shutting the whole world
down because everything just got shut
down so i went straight went straight to
the casino and cashed my check
straight to the casino and cast my check
and flew home with all cash and they
were like
the guy was like are you are you serious
man i was like hey yeah i am like i
don't trust what's gonna go on in the
world right now give me my money right
now i'm just probably hurting like not
please we don't have it sir
[Laughter]
yeah man i'm glad they stuck with
brittany and ariana for so long i know
that they they uh
they loyal to those girls sean you don't
touch hands for your fight either dude
um no i don't really like it man people
use that to decide to measure you up
mm-hmm you know i remember the first
time uh i ever heard nobody like say
touch hands i was fighting forrest
griffin
at the weigh-ins he's like tomorrow
don't touch my glove
let's just fight and i was like
he was so nice
he was so nice before that
but he don't touch gloves man just came
out just fighting you don't make sure
you fight different coming out mentally
you know yeah you know why i never did
it
john madsen
remember he he he ducked under and shot
on abe took it out yeah and all day and
made one together both passive and touch
gloves yeah i was like nope learning my
lesson quick hey so this dude right here
chaos williams he from
uh the same gym that i was from in
lansing michigan this boy got heat in
his hands yeah oh my gosh chaos he got
some heat in his hands from lansing huh
yeah from lansing so he's trained he's
trained by my uh old coach joaquin mercy
uh joaquin rodriguez
he's with team mercy lago okay yeah my
god son uh devin devin smith
he's living with me now but he's from
that
school yeah
but they got they got a nice little
small it's a small it's a small gym
smaller
lebron is so nasty though oh my goodness
uh joe i was going to ask you about uh
big gloves of little gloves like if you
felt um it was a huge change for me too
do you feel like vulnerable like because
it's because the defense is so different
the offense is so different
i just felt like uh
i still like to this day don't feel
comfortable sparring with little gloves
i feel like i like i'm gonna hurt
somebody if i hit them and that's why i
don't do it and then i'm going through a
training camp not connecting because i'm
afraid i'm gonna hit the guy you know
yeah
um but yeah it was a huge difference you
put boxing gloves on me i mean that's
i feel like yeah yeah you know
got him he got him you got him you got
it hit him
it was wow he was funny he was wobbly
looked back like yep
but he tried to play it off like he
wasn't shook but
when you rock man you can't even fake it
your legs go down man
no i get hit one time like that it was
carry town off with a jab and i thought
your legs went down my whole body would
know literally
and i was like don't you dare let him
see that and that's the worst part you
like i'm not really hurt like i'm here
but my my body's [ __ ] like you're
just there you're like they're coherent
but your body starts doing a funny thing
like it's just like you can't feel it
i've never gotten that in a fight but
i've had those flashes where it was like
boom and my legs just went out and i'm
like totally coherent the whole time
like what the [ __ ] did i get down here
you know oh like so you were dropped
yeah where you just boom you hit your
legs go out and you're still 100 there
do you think that it's um
what's it what do you think would be an
easier transition for a fighter now
would it be easier to transition from
mma to uh kickboxing or kickboxing mma
chaos about to get tough
uh
and do you think the sport of
kickboxing's uh evolved because mma's
involved so much
um
i think mma has just ran it just keeps
evolving at such a so much faster pace
than i think kickboxing's always been
trying you know glory and uh
and lion fight and whatnot i've been
trying to to make that thing but i just
mma it's just it ran away went away with
it
and there's so many aspects of him
oh yeah there's so many so many aspects
dude chaos about to get tired randy
brown is worried to fight because you
know the long dudes that are so long and
they're awkward to fight because you're
trying to hit them and they should be
there but they find some way to move out
the way mm-hmm that's randy brown right
now man
he's like one of those floaty things you
see on the side of the road yeah right
you think you can reach his head and
she's floating away yeah yeah
you throwing everything to catch him
look
chaos throwing everything to catch him
um talking about long long long skinny
fighters with long limbs what do you
think about john jones michelle
athletically is he the best ever yeah
athletically for sure yeah i mean look
like he's he's got a skill set but how
he put it together you know not only
that like
you know he he has
[ __ ] up [ __ ] going on outside the cage
and to be able to manage that right and
to be able to not you know i'm saying
unflappable
in spite of that like how do you do that
you know what i'm saying i've i've had
some stuff going on in my life and
my fights directly correlated to that
you know what i'm saying so we've got
i just don't understand how
he does that so that's another reason
why i got uh
i think that he's like
one one of the best ever
i mean
i don't i don't know if he will ever get
you know
the respect or just the recognition i
should say the recognition you know what
i'm saying because of how he lived his
life personally personally
but i mean
because you were down there in jackson
for a while right yeah yeah yeah you
were one of the originators of jackson
too weren't you oh yeah oh yeah no
you're just nothing but a trailblazer
that's me it was me uh
me keith jardine keith keith jardine
brought me down from the from the
ultimate fighter show yeah yeah what's
he doing now what's his life like
movies
yeah i've been doing a little bit last
over the last couple years yeah yeah
it's been good yeah
you enjoy it huh yeah it's fun it's
funny oh you see that hook right there
yeah i can't hurt
but it did oh he blew a kiss yeah
that's what he used to do you got in
trouble for that like these they were
complaining but you didn't get in
trouble but they complained about it all
the time when i fought for griffin
and like he was getting off on me the
first round right getting off on me just
ahead of me just a couple steps ahead of
me
he was getting off on me i was against
cage and like he threw a flurry of
punches and the crowd was screaming as
they feel like he was going to finish me
yeah and after he got done i was like
suck my dick [ __ ]
i remember they were like he's so
disrespectful
but that's what i felt like that's what
i'm [ __ ] side like that's that fight
dude i'm saying [ __ ] come on
that's why i do this [ __ ] you know
that's that sickness like that's that
part you know
yeah i remember i
i dropped like more than once i've
dropped somebody and like my initial
reaction is like get up [ __ ]
in reality i want you to stay down and
get the accounts over i'm trying to get
paid
what comes out you got to try some this
man yeah yeah swear to god man it's a
little spicy but
joe can handle spicy he's too delicate
he got those soft
that's right that's it yeah
roger
it's really good yeah really so this guy
that was really good this guy right here
he um
is a back-to-back world champion for uh
lamb
in australia this dude cooks the best
lamb in the world for like three years
in a row world champion yeah you have a
lamb cooking contest dude they have
everything cooking kindness another
buddy of mine mike uh from sugarfire in
indianapolis or i'm sorry from st louis
dude is like the he's literally the
hamburger world champion of two of
twenty one cookies
hey uh if y'all got nothing going on
memphis in may is next weekend and uh my
wife and i my fat friend wood couple
other dudes we're all going at memphis
may get weird let's have a great time
i've heard about wood oh yeah six five
four hundred pounds got a lisp bald head
you know what the governor i think you
know what the funny thing about a lisp
is everybody that has it can't say it
[Laughter]
look that's the meanest trick ever
somebody's like i'll [ __ ] you
funny
oh damn i'll get you
right there no problem that's a good
looking rug though ties the room
together
joe you want some of this action here
okay i was getting tired though man
around your breasts i'm telling you
oh check
oh oh man come on chaos
chad did you get your feet wet before
the fight
like wet them before i do yeah like like
on the canvas you got the canvas wet
yeah you have to me too why is that
like why does that help tacify your feet
because like yeah cause you have to you
got the you got the uh the dirt and oil
from backstage oh yeah they want you and
then once you wipe them off there
you're wiping them so you got the
traction
that um it was i mean it was i always
had a great time like i remember when i
was like my walk-ins kind of evolved
like what i wanted to do and how i did
it how i handled myself when i first
walked in the cage you like when did you
start doing that crouch and why did you
start doing that for
why yeah
because i'm a wrestler
and i always wanted
to let them know
how it was gonna end
how i was gonna what i was about i
wanted to know what i was gonna do
so i would come in down low crunch
because my whole style was really really
low
i would stay really low and really wide
and i would go like this
but i knew you know i wanted to let them
know
and it kind of like
it put me in a mind like
like um like i got like a like a monkey
style you know yeah and that's a while
so you really did approach that that was
a fighting was a mental game for you
yeah and it really was sounds like it
that's why
you had you had the same approach was it
like that or you just get let's [ __ ]
scrap let's go i was like just like
[ __ ] turn a switch and like go
do you feel like you're a different
person when you fight than you are all
the time 100 i think like within like
two days of the fight i'm like people
that are really close with me like
they're like kind of standoffish because
like i'm the guy that's like walking
around grunting and like there's like
steam radiant off of me like i'm uh i'm
uh pretty uh
intense when it comes to that yeah you
know
but it was always like just proving
myself prove myself and improve myself
i think that most people would probably
disagree with me but i don't think i was
i think i always it was just like this
when i would go fight i don't think i
was any different other than be like all
right let's go get paid let's go get
i'll tell you which fight it was there
were a couple where you look real pissed
off yeah real pissed off going into the
fight oh
oh oh oh oh oh god that chaos is drunk
driving
drunk driving
oh goodness good thing he tied him up
does randy brown know he is though
no
you didn't even know it
i think
i think if you if you're if you're
fighting now and you don't have any
wrestling background you don't belong
fighting one bit hey it's keep talking
about that is kickboxing is it alive
still or was it is it a dead sport i
don't know it's uh i think glory's
putting on for glory coming back couple
are they i mean i've seen them signing a
bunch of people but i haven't seen
really a lot of this yeah i'm gonna tell
you right now i hope they do come back
one of the best events i've ever seen
was overseas when tyrone fought uh in
istanbul
yeah the istanbul shows are ridiculous
that's the one where he broke his leg
oh fought a goat hockey yeah he fought
sake yo and that that was that was a
real that was like a movie like you see
like one of rocky movies rockets in
russia
but it was like they had like in the
stadium it was like an old basketball
stadium so it kind of had still like
those wood uh
the wood bleachers so they started like
hitting the bleachers stump in a
bleachers and it was deafening bro it
was definitely they were going crazy and
i seen tyrone in the back and tyrone
normally is like
like tyrone's a fighter fighter you know
like he's just like god go out there
knock him out yeah don't care like he
just cool like he chilled out you know
but this fight he was lathered up like
he was almost speaking in tongues before
he went out there he was just lathered
up because the environment just had him
had him just there so when he went out
there and he fought thinking about it
when he went out there and he fought
like he was like fighting like with a
different kind of spirit and he threw
that leg kick
and it was like
no matter how loud that's damn stating
was you heard that snap oh god and he
went down
and i looked at him across the cage when
he tried to get up and he just like
it was the saddest look everybody i'm
saying this is like oh my god i was just
gutted for man cause he knew right then
it was done oh my god dude and that was
a big fight for a man but that was it
was huge oh my god that was like the
biggest fight in the world at that
moment like that sport that was like
yeah holy [ __ ] these cats are gonna be
an amazing fight man amazing fight
those guys are like taki and splunk were
like my heroes
dude it was it was such a pleasure to be
able to watch um overeem uh oh my god
you remember that oh remember that yo
that was one of the best things i've
ever seen oh my god
tyrone spong and ah that's the orbeez
bar and for training
god unreal man just him
fun it was unreal man it was unreal like
and and it was ubereat that was uber
yeah yeah uber and this they have such a
history together like they were trained
together when they were kids and then
they had like their little separation
where they had beef and then they fought
and then now they're on the same team
again and before even aleister or joined
the team
uh you know glenn we you know glenn
glenn got it you know asked tyrone like
yo could we have alistar on the team so
they were still kind of like getting to
know each other again reacquainted you
know what i'm saying and you can still
kind of tell like
there was still a little tension you
know what i'm saying behind the old [ __ ]
so when they sparred it was like
the first day there everyone's just kept
watching them get closer and closer
next round let's go remember
about it and was trying to put the
things up in the case yeah yeah he
didn't want nobody to see man no no
because he
hey dude it was like
it was the most fun i ever had to watch
any fight and there was watching them in
practice no way well listen no but
that's what that but that camp though
tyrone was scary as [ __ ] that camp
yo tyrone in that camp
was
and and no more like he was an animal
normal at this camp he was sick man he
was sick dude
he's so good he he's hit me
sometimes i was like dude that just
[ __ ] sucks like good god like bro
i'll tell you he gets he's mad at me oh
my yo you got him
wow um he got mad at me for saying this
he actually uh he like tweeted me or
some [ __ ] like that i said the hardest
i'd ever been punched both the two
hardest times i've ever been punched in
my life was by anthony johnson uh and
when he broke he broke my orbital bone
in practice one time and then another
time i can't remember what it was and i
was like dude that
like the hardest i've ever been punched
was was anthony a.j no no question about
it aj is the reason i stopped sparring
and practice
he's the reason i stopped sparring
you know yeah you told me years ago you
stopped running
yo aj
i've never seen nobody knock out more
people in practice than aj duke really
it was like it was like
yo aj yeah we were training together too
oh [ __ ]
oh that makes me so anxious when i see
that coming that knee going up
yeah dude aj dude there was a time
dude this kid came off a wall like they
were scrambling scrambled scrambling and
aj gave him a little space and it came
off and must have dropped his hands on
aj threw a high kick i'm pink dude this
happened hold it up like a suitcase then
aj's height kick bro oh it comes it
comes like
it comes so fast and you know how like
somebody like he's not a lefty but you
know like somebody has like a natural
swing right it's so fast and it comes so
unorthodox it just like
you can't really control it he's not
quite you know he's getting joy he's
just throws it it's just exactly that's
exactly right it's like his muscles are
so tight that it just goes and it just
yeah
a lot of people uh i find that um you're
right your left kick is actually better
than your right kick because you over
you over analyze and you overwork your
right leg and you try to control it and
you end up [ __ ] up with yeah whereas
like your left just comes out like a
natural swing
because you don't bother trying because
you can't control it you just let it rip
oh
uh whenever i see somebody start
spinning that just bothers me so you
guys you guys were just full but when
they called it meat meat practice oh
yeah oh yeah me nobody's pulling nothing
oh yeah yeah
dude back in the day that was do you
remember everybody that was in that camp
yeah i mean thiago silva like uh
belfort
is the best dude you haven't heard of oh
man yo this dude guto
bro dude he was terrifying guto
innosenche if you get a chance to look
at him yeah he got some he got something
what do you call it what do you call it
thug jitsu dug jitsu
like jitsu or something like that
that cat
his thai boxing is nasty because it's
mixed with like
what kind of martial arts like i feel
like yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah oh you see bro did you
see him fight uh when he fought rico
over at hooven
hit him with this dump and like sent oh
yeah
shout out to him best best [ __ ] dump
i've ever seen
but he would do that in practice all the
time and i'd be like dude look at that
guy you never know what to do
never he like fakes the cake and steps
behind just like one of these
like
and he just [ __ ] wailed on me yes
that's one of the things though like
being part of uh
like the camp with henry hooves and
tyrone spung those guys they had a
connection to the dutch community you
know what i'm saying so a lot of people
from holland and over in europe they
will come over to our camp and we got
some of the best like fighters in the
world known for like you know what i'm
saying like ernesto hoose uh
um rob cayman gay men in the house rob
cave crate robert rob came in crazy as
[ __ ]
yo rob craven is crazy right yeah he but
he's the best man he's the best you ever
see his feet before what's that his feet
his feet
yo his feet is he got gnarly feet yeah
gnarly because he been yo i never yo
after i've seen his feet i'm like man i
don't know fighting for me hey
y'all ask me tripped me out but you know
what really tricks me out when i forget
to take my uh my happy hippo herbal
supplement it makes my brain work it's
kratom i use kratom to fight my brain
i've just started doing it i took it
today and i feel like my mind is on
point today kids i'm telling you
brendan's always telling me about it
he's like listen you got to try this
kratom it's absolutely fantastic it is
the best focused product he's like
listen you're going to love it you
should take it it's all natural it's
really really dope but don't take my
word for it don't take brennan's word
for it visit
happyhappyhippos.com use promo code
thick boy that's a triple c thick boy
for 20 off for life shot for life not
just one time for life well i mean you
make it sound so good let me get some of
that hunger hippo hey you you use hey
you use that code whenever you want hey
y'all go to happy hippo herbals.com
use that code
triple stick boy 20 off use it many
times you want thank you
man yeah
that was tough man that was good you did
good very good
conversation i'm saying i didn't want to
lose the time
i appreciate that though boys thanks
you got to worry about that you know
that avoid me
that dude's got a long he's got a long
frame and that dude can be dangerous and
he's look he's sloppy right now he's got
to grow into it but
he did a good job man good for him
what's the um do you guys do you guys
follow the sport right now do you follow
mma yeah yeah kind of yeah for the most
part
yeah so like you guys have an
up-and-comer that's gonna be like oh
this guy might be pretty damn salty
right now it might be kind of good
oh man
nope
that's awesome no i don't follow sport
at all
i can't think of anybody right now like
that i watch it when i come here and
[ __ ] with people i care about other
than that i'm
i mean there's definitely some guys that
i think you know got some got some
skills you know what i'm saying
like i i love uh
to watch cory sanhagen corey san hagen's
one of my favorite to watch man that
dude the way the way he moved in there
you know what i'm saying like he's got
that he's got that flow style that i
just like he just never seems out of
balance no matter if he through some
[ __ ] that just completely missed he know
how to make it work you know i really
love guys who just like mastery and just
so masterful that moving like like izzy
is he so dope the way he moved like he's
so he just makes it so like makes the
violence look so beautiful you know what
i'm saying the way everything is just
you know dramatic but it's like very on
point and it's just razor sharp and
precise man
like i thought i thought for sure
like the net like the the last fight
that robert whittaker had like he was
gonna be able to like compete with him a
little bit better but i mean is he
showed that he's he's grown you know i'm
saying even more than he was before so
it's like
you guys are going to strongly disagree
with me i'm sure about this there is one
fighter that i
stylistically
would love to see fight izzy
and that's michael venompage
i think mvp
has such a creative and athletic style
and he's evasive and he's cocky and he
has the same attitude mentally yeah that
i feel that would be needed to be able
to compete in that level and not lose
before you even step in the cage 100
percent and i feel that that dude has
such a talent level
to see those two scrap would be [ __ ]
poetic it's definitely gonna take
somebody with the confidence that
michael the page has
yeah yeah because anybody else that's
like doubting it when he goes out there
and starts doing his yeah you're just
going to like
kind of fall apart yeah that's the thing
about it so with the
with romero where like they just don't
they don't pull the trigger you know
yeah and then like there's no question
that romero's a bad [ __ ] but
when you get in there and you're if
you're doubting you're you're striking
with somebody like that you're just not
gonna
you're not gonna go do it if you just
get caught watching yeah pretty much
wasn't it
wasn't it forrest griffin
that was talking about his fight with
anderson and he was like dude he's like
i was
throwing everything i could as well as i
could throw it i never felt better and
that dude literally played with my hands
until he wanted to touch me i remember
anderson came up to 205. yeah and he was
like he's like dude he's like that's
when he ran out
remember that's when force went out he
was like i didn't he's like i was so
overwhelmed i didn't know what to do and
anderson hit him with a little baby
check
check check jabs
but see that's what and that's when
anderson was like in his like neo zone
like that's when he was the one you know
what i'm saying like he was [ __ ] neo
at that time like he was just seeing
movement way different just so
comfortable with that movement and just
like just playing people just playing
like a a beautiful symphony of just
amazing violence he was so so talented
man like really impressive and and the
way he the way he approached it was so
like he was in my mind i don't know a
whole lot about the sport
but in my mind he was the first one that
really um
navigated athleticism to the sport like
he was
purely athletic with an ability just to
have timing and reach he just knew
exactly what it was yeah yeah and i
don't think there was anybody like that
before him and then jon jones just
changed the game once
when i when i first seen anderson silva
i remember i was there on his premiere
fight he was fighting uh chris lieben
and uh yeah yeah i was on a fight
fighting stefan bonner
and
i remember getting warmed up
and this dude just sleeping underneath
the damn
uh dresser the whole time and not the
dress of the whole like the sink you
know that was in the changing room
because at the old hard rock back then
we were in the changing rooms and like
you know the bathroom that's where we
get ready so he'll sleep underneath the
sink the whole time i go out and do my
fight i come back he's still sleeping
you know what i'm saying then then
somebody else goes out and fighting then
he goes out and then he finally goes he
wakes up stretches for like five minutes
oh it's time time
goes out there and piece up chris
leaving i'm just like yo who is this
dude oh god well i was gonna say when
when he came to the ufc he already had
the cage rage experience the pride
experience like he came over with a ton
of experience already i think yeah what
he did to tony frickland know that
oh that elbow god oh my god dude i've
tried to practice so many times and like
never works ever throw the way he set
that up yo let's see what is fruit
talking about though
there we go
if you're ready for that i'm ready for
that yeah yeah i mean it looks
absolutely delicious
it's got a good charm too
yeah that might be a little too much for
you i've never seen i've never done
grilled fruit before i'm i'm down though
and that cinnamon on top of it yeah the
cinnamon
that looks like a tahini too well i'll
tell you what you're going to get
i i might even be jealous of you right
now shall i
you know
you gotta try that i got you
um hey there's cannon there i know it's
fighting everybody's got chances can
never have a shot at this or is is he
just so so quick
i think he's a wrestler right
he's a gunner he throws hands yeah he's
a gun bro
but um
yeah
i mean i think he's got the mindset for
it
um athleticism talent for it but
the way he fought robert whitaker at one
time
to me he was just kind of like
almost a little too content with just
allowing that momentum to shift and not
buckle back you know maybe that's the
first time being on the big statement
and he's learned from that but i just
feel like
i haven't seen overall confidence in
this game god i think he's gonna be able
to stand up against izzy's confidence
you know yeah
but he's had a hell of a growth but is
he like like i said he's just a
different animal right now the other
thing is like how long is he gonna stay
perfect for you for uh you know
the world in the excitement and all this
stuff like wears on him you know stay
like this then you know who knows i'm
not the world good to him right right
but he's out here in that late night
right look at hallie i don't know dude i
think he moved to america
did he move to america yeah i think so
dude it's it's it's a lot of state
the the demand that they put on uh the
champs and the can and the high
contenders
is
is exhausting i can only imagine i've
seen it from you know a lot of my
friends um and i've seen like that you
guys don't get you guys don't really
have privacy anymore you don't like your
time's not your time anymore um you
don't it's almost it's the gift and the
curse it's what hey i'm so glad i had it
but damn i wish i never experienced it
almost
yeah i mean yeah i mean that's the thing
about it like to be able to
have that experience and then
maintaining perspective is really hard
because
like it's the people around you that
changes more than you change at first
you know and then you start changing
because everybody starts to treat you
differently and then you start you know
change is required of you right you know
growth has changed which isn't a bad
thing we always got to in our mind that
change is such a bad thing but change is
is a healthy thing but
being able to stay focused brand is hard
i was told i would imagine all of a
sudden you got all the money all the
fame yeah everybody loves you everybody
wants your friend you know
eventually
you know maybe you only stumble once
then you come back to it or whatever but
like anybody might get you it might be
that time yeah i mean but everybody like
once you first start
yeah once you first start get once you
first ride that elevator right you know
what i'm saying elevator of success
you know you kind of forget a little bit
you know i'm saying you kind of get a
little detached you kind of get caught
up in the hype it pulls you in it's the
allure of it all you know what i'm
saying it pulls you in
uh but
you get you you get brought down and you
just like oh you know the elevator goes
up and it goes down too you know but you
understand
the dynamic of a two should that
elevator go back up try one of those
pairs now i'm telling them
it changed your life right wow
bro just like my shoes change your life
man um
do you uh
is he's undefeated at uh at midway right
at 85 correct yeah do you fear
that the first time he loses at 85 he's
a completely different dude because
gutholson was too right gusson was
undefeated until he got smoked and once
he got smoked
gussen
wasn't really gusting anymore and then
they say the same thing about um till
right yeah till wasn't really well until
he wasn't and then all of a sudden poof
like do you or do you have any concern
that that izzy might be that same way
i don't know because i've cause i've
seen him lose before he's lost in other
sports yeah and he's got a ton of
experience yeah he's lost
yeah
that's a good conversation to have yeah
i was in there tuning that microphone
like i didn't belong here i think it was
great it feels good huh it was really
good as i told you it was much much more
gooder than i expected it to be
i'm really happy i did that
um
i might think he has like the confidence
to handle that situation but there's
been a lot of a lot of fighters way
better than me that as soon as they lost
they just couldn't handle that pressure
or they were so alleviated that they
lost we got a buddy he's an actor he's
he's a big name
and um i was talking about some stuff
and i was like hey man do you ever you
ever wish you put the genie back in the
bottle you know like because your life
is totally different than i like they're
so big mainstream wise like they're
totally different conversation
and he's like he's like dude he's like i
promise you he's like at least once a
day i wish to myself i could just go
back to being a plumber
he's like he's like i have to rent out
restaurants in order to go have dinner
and enjoy myself see that's tough to be
a prisoner of it
when you're a prisoner of it right
that's tough i feel like i'm at a
comfortable level you know what i'm
saying well you were really you were big
big famous for a long time
right you were weren't you you were you
were weren't you the first black champ
weren't you
whoa or a trailblazer for the black
champion yeah yeah definitely
trailblazer for the black champion yeah
like do you carry that you carried a big
torch whether you wanted to or not yeah
for sure i did for sure i did but i
really never felt it was like a big
torch like that i felt it was just
me being me
yeah
but that's it you know chuck broke my
heart you don't chuck was my hero you
don't feel that you kind of like you
were the the catalyst for the gender for
the next generation of black fighters
because they saw it like yeah 100 like i
feel like i brought a lot of black
fighters into the game like a lot of
them tell me that like yo
you know i watched you growing up
and it's like it's like one of those
things that just make me proud because
it gives me perspective like
man you know what no matter how i felt i
did about any of those fights the fact
that i was able to go out and inspire
these men to go out there and change
their lives that's a ripple effect man
you know what i'm saying that's a ripple
effect dude it's i i joke with you a lot
i care about you obviously we're good
friends um i am always uh in awe
of your humility
um and the the
the simple fashion in which you present
yourself you're a complicated ass dude
here there's nothing simple about you
um
but
you live simply you live modestly you're
a great human being and i always
appreciate um the way in which you
mentor and take time and conversate with
people that
you might not ever even see again
but you take time with them and i see it
time and time and time again um and it
could be it could be a hindrance to your
schedule it could like people could be
tugging on you hey we gotta go we gotta
go chill out
i got this let me let me say a couple
more things real quick and i always see
that and i've always valued the way that
you present
uh yourself your time your worth to
other people thank you man i appreciate
that you know uh
i just remember like one time um
i know he can get mad at me when i say
this but
the first time i met antonio tarver
like i was a fan like a big fan
and now you know people go through
different things right and i'm sure
people got stories of me like oh i
remember shot one time and you know he
would say what's up to me or something
but like i went up to antonio tower i
told my wife at the time like yo yo yo
that's antonio tarver and i was in the
boxing i go up to him and i'm like yo
what's up and he was just like the way
he just dismissed me i was just like
i was heartbroken you know what i'm
saying and i was like you know what man
i never want anybody to feel like that
you know i'm saying if i can help it
i never want to make anybody feel like
that because i mean you know you don't
you don't understand the impact that you
may have just when somebody's seeing you
they may have been just like they may be
having just like a [ __ ] up day you
know then they see you and they're just
like oh [ __ ] man things are going to get
better i just see rashad evans you know
you're not going to be totally honest
with you i think shogun who is a career
bad body leader
like he's i can't listen i can't throw
salt on anybody but i'm just saying that
dude
that dude has a career
like
if you could if you could neatly in
organized fashion stack up bubble gum
that might be what you get
i really hope that this goes better than
i think it's gonna go oh my head look
right now and when i saw the weigh-in it
wasn't good i didn't see the way in
what happened he looked like that
but he [ __ ] fought in a long time i
mean i [ __ ] love you too you look
like that
you know what's funny about i'm talking
about this i was just commenting him let
me tell you this i find it hysterical
really i do
how many people like when i when like
they find out that we're friends with
everyone we'll talk about whatever like
we're you and i are chatting up on on
social like we used to or whatever like
like people were like dude he i'm so
[ __ ] scared of him like i'm so
terrified of him like are you scared of
joe dude like joe's one of the nicest
dudes i know like and he's like he just
looks what he does his voice sounds the
way he does he pulls down heaters the
way he does like like this dude told me
he's like i've never seen anybody look
so angry smoking a cigarette and i was
like you know what i was like yeah joe
smoke that [ __ ] like he mean
he'd be pulling off that [ __ ] like it's
like like when they made camel when they
made like the camel
what the [ __ ] i got that knuckling
just absolutely face everyone thinks i'm
like super angry mean guys hey you know
what's funny dude
i'm just throwing heat on you you're
always gonna be casting the bad guy yeah
you're always the villain dude that's
always a villain i'm all right
always a villain like
you might be like the professional
that's like the hitman killer that ends
up being good but you're always there
man killer but guess what though that's
good though man cause listen bad guys
are underestimated though man you think
yeah i'm telling you come on movies are
you talking
about yeah
and i'm always ma'am
maybe man
did you um i read the how old the show
gonna look to you right now
oh man how old does he look
body wise or face wise all of it
and he's got so much mileage on him he
bought 40 something he looked 40
something
that's not no i know he's not though i
know he's like 30 something no way he's
crazy right crazy dude he looks like
yeah i'm 50. he looks like 50 something
yo the sugar matt don't make sense
40.
see i'm almost 70s babies myself so
how many how many babies i mean babies
uh how many uh fights does he have can
you look that up here
shogun yeah yeah yeah
and his style never changed either
oh he's gonna attack that gut
oh osp caught him it was a osp was a
late second stand-in right and then
knocked him out in like 20 seconds oh
yeah with it with a straight line that's
right it looked like he was on the scene
he's got 40 fights
then they made that gift
yeah didn't they make that gift that he
was slipped on a skateboard no that's
right i was terrible
yeah
dude the internet is undefeated yeah i
know man i'm just always oh you know
what another 85er i just thought about
that i think
would be a great fight with izzy
oh mousasi
who saucy would be i [ __ ] love
musashi dude he's a great player he's
going i love him in fighting and i think
he's such a fun dude to be around
musashi he's so chill dude
i just saw like the dutch people in the
dutch attitude in general those were
always like my favorite people like
henry
henry's henry's the chill dude they're
so like
blunt
and uh yeah there's no there's no uh
confusion about how they feel they like
you they like you if they don't like oh
yeah you know he's a piece of [ __ ] but
it's okay it's cool [ __ ] him he can be
your friend your friend is not mine yeah
i love that yeah that's what um we were
talking about aj before about his uh his
high kick
yeah he threw uh
what was it like i think it was a
it would be his right high kick and then
came with a superman punch over the top
of it that's your gun y'all gonna look
like he still got some stinks yeah he
still got it
got a little stink on that punch show
huh
hey but look at his body already look at
saint prue was taking it to that body
i mean do you think about mentality why
shogun
he should i would i think i would say
shogun should win this fight just
because ability-wise it might slow down
a little bit
he can hang on with this fight you don't
think so
get the same submission again
no way you think how much you got of
those
it's the bomb blue choke for this you
call it the same proof you got straight
left he find it he found it
you know what shogun's missing though
what's that remember how he has that's
not what i mean
see
childish for that
child
he don't got that no more yeah he's very
straight very straight up yo there it is
he just almost did it a little bit
and then
st proof got the right ideas like how
many looking at that belly like i'm just
going to keep kicking
this you know why because he's about
eight of them already he's too square
sean's way too square
see before he'll get away with that
squareness because he'll be moving the
shoulders like i was just showing before
you know
but oh my gosh he gonna kick his chest
off do i i can't imagine having a fight
i was shot how many fights you have
about 30 something yeah joe
i don't know that many uh
yeah i don't know uh
uh right around
that looks so slow you see that
that's how you call him last time he
literally just shuffled into that and
threw an overhand right it was almost
the same thing that caught him last time
he came and run like that against the
cage and then saint proof stepped out
hit him with that left hook and if it
looked like he fell on skateboard
that was
it might happen again are you moving his
shoulders huh he's listening to you uh
somewhere around like 40
43 i think maybe pro it might happen
again oh
oh wow that could have been a good hook
oh
yeah
remember in practice when like you'd be
kicking somebody in the body and they're
really gross and sweaty and your feet
are all slippery afterwards yeah like i
just can't do that anymore i don't know
if i'm from him i'm feeling pretty good
watching his his chest turn red and the
darker it gets the better i feel this is
going damn his his chest looks like he's
gonna be hurting too well i mean there's
some like right in the center it's
getting better dark the dark red and i'm
like so he looks so old when he's trying
to walk when he's trying to stalk him
down he looks just
oh you know that low kick hurts though
yeah dude i mean he's in there though
shot the first time i've ever ever moved
around with joe
we're in we're now laying something for
bellator or something yeah and joe was
there and i was like man let's move
around a little bit let's get a little
something and do joe just this guy goes
i don't spar anymore i'm like oh okay
and he said well let's move around i'm
like all right no gloves got big matt
just throwing throwing punches bare
knuckle at my face
he's fast and he's he's mad twitchy yeah
and sometimes it comes with control but
sometimes that should just go a little
bit far out and the only thing he got is
a sorry to offer afterwards
yeah right exactly and he hit way too
hard for that man yo
joe was whipping my ass joe threw like a
quintuple jab and then hit me with a
two-piece in the uppercut and i was like
i have had enough based on the situation
we were in i was like i'm just gonna
throw a [ __ ] ton of punches at him so he
stays away from me that was that was
what happened how'd it work yeah we'll
see how uh how shogun comes out in
second round that'll be like the real
test here
look amazing man he looked good though
man shogun listen honestly he don't look
bad the pressure that he has going
forward yeah you know i mean his body
may not look the hottest but he's he's
bringing it though yeah he bringing it
oh he was pressuring it
for sure
he's too square though he's got he's
gotta he's gotta rock that body like how
he used to do before
bro when you're your chest is bloodshot
from from front kicks
sternum
not feeling good you know it's i think
it's cool like when you
you learn how to be a pressure fighter
and go forwards and put and move
somebody backwards it's really difficult
for a striker to go to strike well going
backwards um i think that's one of the
things talking about tyrone spong i
think that's one thing that tyrone does
that i never felt from anybody before is
his forwards pressure i mean that dude
is he's damn near and i feel like i can
go forward against anybody and
tyrone makes me really uncomfortable
yeah it's that pressure that says
suffocating pressure you know what i'm
saying that you just
you he's not really doing anything but
he's looking busy he's looking like he's
always
setting you up and you're sitting there
paranoid trying to yeah see what he's
seeing that's spacious yeah yeah he's
smaller he's smaller yeah
and then also he just touch you with a
jab you're like oh my god you did all
that just touch me to jab like jeez
and he didn't see it he was almost there
yeah he's just there he's like
yeah
he faints at you
you know what one of my favorite videos
of tyrone is is that one where um i
actually see it on reels every once in a
while that dude comes out ding ding ding
knocks tyrone down michael in like five
seconds i know he just says hold this up
there and pink people oh friend like
cats
so i was with him that fight right yeah
and uh he was training with uh pedro
diaz
him and pedro diaz got a like a very
funny relationship you know they always
joking around but when it's time to work
it's time to work so he he told tyrone
before you go out there he said hey hey
mate
don't get lazy no leap man hey no leap
that means no sleep don't be sleeping
you know stay tight when you go out
there be ready tyrone went out there and
got
flash knocked down
pedro hey no late mate no link
he was coaching him
i remember watching that and then like
his range finder he just left his hand
out there just to make sure and good god
once he connected it was like a damn
atom bomb went off in that dude's face
and that's a good thing like you see
fighters that use the frame effect of
this because sometimes you can use a
frame too long and it actually gets you
messed up
but like some guys can use it so
effectively shogun can use it
effectively when he uses it but like i
don't know man
i wonder what his point is like what
you're trying to do like i don't see any
aggressive attack and i don't see him
trying to swarm him and throw more than
one or two punches at a time
so his low kicks they seem just kind of
just
just something to do so so so what he's
doing is this right here he's using he's
you he uses like a battering ram type
thing so he batters rams you forward and
use this as a guard and wait for you to
go either way and when you peel off then
he blitzes you with the
and you're defensively compromised
because you're moving on the outside and
then he may catch you with a clip like
how he called machida okay he's kind of
using that out there to keep like a
barrier to slow the pace of the fight to
keep you at there so you're not you're
not charging you're not coming forward
on them yeah one way just got somebody
here so i can throw
you know what it looks like uh i don't
think i don't think i've seen too many
mma fighters with better kick defense
than uh than who would though
like everything that comes in high or
low body kick other than that that mid
body yeah he's doing a good job with his
they go is it me or is it like who's
face changing like but it's changing
like it's looking like
like
in that in a look at look at his eyes
like a different person he looks like he
looks like a cartoon character of a
a villain you would draw like yeah he
doesn't look like a villain like he
looks like a bill like yeah he's a bad
guy he's a bad guy this guy's definitely
the bad guy you know
he's the bad guy he's the bad guy for
sure
yeah he's a bad guy you know it
oh
but you know what's getting him though
because that kick return in return
i love counter kicks you joe
counter kick you're a counter kick guy
yeah
yeah wow did you see how fast that left
come out from osp
good god he's coming do you remember
when we talked to um
eddie alvarez
and eddie said one time about fighting
connor that it wasn't necessarily the
power of conor it was how fast connor's
straight left went from conor's set
position to eddie's chin and it was hard
for him to set his neck in order to
absorb it or to to
to hold the punch and he said it got to
his face so fast
and i was i would probably say that was
the same as fedor fedor was so
so fast from set to my face
whoo
thank god it only happened one time yeah
how fast how fun was it though fighting
fatal it was like it was like were you
sitting there looking across from like
yo
this is fedor like did you have like
that moment during the fight i had a
moment where i was like i was like
excited the whole week i was like i
don't mean anything to me i don't i
don't follow him but [ __ ] stop man just
pimping that game you know so like
i walked in the cage
and i was there i was looking at him i
was like
this might get really weird really fast
man the double knockdown was insane
i literally thought to myself i was like
hey man at least we just got paid a
whole lot of money
like then like ding ding is like all
right [ __ ] it let's go like here it goes
here it goes and then boom you both go
down and you got up and jumped on top of
them yeah
it was nuts that was like out of a movie
man yeah straight up out of a movie yeah
yeah i'm in the mushroom and it was um
it was out of a movie and it was it was
terrifying literally terrifying because
i saw his head hit the ground i was like
dude if you do not finish this [ __ ]
fight right now it is going to suck for
you i was like all right let's go that's
what it looks like
like i literally like oh my
god don't please don't stand up please
don't stand up
that's the worst man when you get tired
and your opponent has more energy he's
coming oh my god oh
you know i had that one time one time
and it was against scott junk
like when i was uh i was fighting it was
my first fight ever so i didn't know
anything about an adrenaline dump and i
was so mad when i fought him i wanted to
really hurt that fight i wanted to hurt
him when you had junk friends though no
i mean we had that deal oh yeah the same
manager yeah yeah and he set us up
beforehand and yeah so we had a deal
that like we going ultimate fighter and
hey we'll get each other through the
first round this was all established
before we went on the show who's your
first man uh my first manager yeah it
was [ __ ] ken pavia
it was the positive it was the pop and
so we had this deal that like you go on
you go on the ultimate fighter and if
we're on separate teams we'll tell each
other we'll tell each other like the
secret who you're fighting whatever else
whatever's going on will get you through
the first round then after afterwards
second round all bets are off we could
fight each other i'll try to kill you no
problem and i was like well i don't know
anybody else in mma he knows i knew
nothing about it i was like why not sure
so i thought we were slick we always had
to wear these little
octagon necklaces yeah
and they had microphones on them so i
took a bowl like a ceramic bowl and i
was talking into the ceramic bowl so the
microphone couldn't pick it up i was
like hey you're fighting your roommate
um justin wren and i'm fighting marcus
jones and i was late at night so i went
downstairs went to bed came up for
breakfast in the morning i was gonna i
toasted a bagel and they're like you
[ __ ] sell out why'd you snitch on
everybody why'd you give away all these
these these uh uh plans like you know
whatever else and i was like
what are you talking about and they're
like scott junk went downstairs last
night and told us you snitched on
everything and then you and i was like
okay
and i couldn't be at the time i couldn't
be like hey man like there's there's
like a 5 million confirmed without the
contestants policy like there was like
some big penalty for it so i couldn't be
like hey this is what happened and i
couldn't tell shot i couldn't tell
anybody so i just like from that point
on i was two weeks into the show so for
the next four weeks it was a six week
long show
for that next six weeks i was a pariah i
was hated bad guy yeah and they're like
you're a [ __ ] you're scared of this
you're scared of that and then like yeah
we don't understand that at all we're
like what's up with this dude man tell
him why are you telling him dude
and i wanted to tell y'all but i just
couldn't
and then like and then i was like and
then i was so bored with myself i was
like well just i'm gonna make turn this
show on it's here there you go that was
it you see that one he did you see that
straight like that he's straight up oh
my gosh
he hurting him now he hurt him he's
finding them oh he's fighting him he's
finding them
looks like if you
oh that one hurt that one hurt he stuck
in he hurt and he hurt in that one bro
how many front kicks has he landed right
yeah
i think i've ever seen this many in an
mma fight you got blitzing on blitz he's
skating yo his chest hurt kick kick the
chest kick the chest kick
he can't take another one he can't take
another one
he but he's he's gunshot he can't take
another one he can't take another one i
think that broke a rib oh i'm telling
you he hurting bad with it he cannot
well if he can't take it we better hug
up on him
he doing everything he can
dude
he yelled [ __ ] in the middle of the
fight shogun did i wonder if he broke a
rib in there
he's hurting him now
you know what i think you might be right
i haven't seen his eyebrows move this
whole time
he's got some really well-trained
caterpillars that dude got some real
good botox
it looks like botox but i don't think
it's botox i think it's the swelling
from getting hit between the eyes you
think so yeah because
saint paul was like damon amen right at
the center man he's hitting his chest
and
you think that's all kicks
yeah that's a whole lot man yo he yeah
that's 21 kicks right there man
do he he fires that left off so fast so
fast it's natural for him look at that
it's going to be so many
so weird now like that hook is all he's
living and dying on
i think it's 1-1 going into this third
round i probably have to agree shogun
went first
you think she'll go on the first well he
had a lot of pressure
that's pretty much the only thing that
happened in it
no saint prue was mark man he was
marking him up was it i think that's a
close round those judges are going to
see the red
oh it's probably good if i took more of
those happy hippo herbals i'd probably
remember what the first round happened i
was going to say that but i gonna throw
under the bus
[Laughter]
i need to make those the pills i'm
popping
see i'm gonna give you some of this
tyson ko on me
right here dude
i wouldn't be able to feel my damn feet
if i tried to do that
you're good you'll be done yeah i ate a
gummy one time and i did i forgot it was
a gummy i forgot i ate it i was on an
airplane and dude i was like
i was so high for like seven hours and i
didn't mean to be at all didn't think
about it
and then i had to go train with henry
and and all these other people and it
was you were there too was in vegas and
like when he cleared out the suite and
we're all up there training and it was
like stroving like nine other people in
there working
dude i was so high i could barely
function i was like what was the night
that uh
my boy ate that uh the mushroom when he
took it out of your hand he ate that
mushroom remember that he was in your
room uh what did i dieted
nah yeah i gave you something then you
ate yeah i believed it
hey man i like the party
you know what i'm saying i mean when it
comes down to it yeah you do
wow guy
all right so you're giving us osp
yeah i got to give to osp man this last
round two to one
how are you gonna run like that for the
last 20 we think he broke his foot
probably his toes throwing all those
front kicks do you remember when jon
jones broke his toe like that that big
toe oh my god when he fought chill
oh could you imagine if chill son and
beat jon jones like that and you almost
beat innocent silva into some crazy dude
you would never ever hear the end of
chill right there no
oh i was digging
there was a uh
who he was a heavyweight and he was a
british dude i think and his toe got
stuck in a puzzle mat and a compound
fracture his big toe compound fractured
off
i mean it was like it was just hanging
on my skin it was so so bad
i barely tell you that could have hurt
him
but see that was not to me that's the
story of the fight though like you've
seen shogun with this great pressure and
occasionally he'll land something but
there was nothing as far as damage is
concerned like you see what osp did to
him yeah
oh my gosh
and him controlling the distance with
that front kick yeah you're controlling
the space right there
dang
what's the setup what's the sponsor set
up with uh with with with the ufc right
now
um everybody gets a percentage of
everything
so you don't have to put a shirt on
anymore no you got to put a shirt on but
you get a percentage of it of it
champions get a different color
the more tenure you are you get a
different cut of it oh yeah
well i'm glad shogun didn't get murdered
in this fight we've been fun to watch
honestly though i mean he he he looked
too bad though no he didn't look bad at
all i feel bad on the [ __ ] i was saying
[ __ ] i mean he looked good that's what i
wanted to see though yeah he looked
pretty good though his pressure was nice
that's a competitive fight
yeah it was competitive
he he's ranked higher in osp didn't he
like ranking wise
i mean when was his last fight
[ __ ] on eight years right yeah
last one i remember when he fought
osprey four years ago no that's the
2019.
no way 2019. or 2018 i think he fought
last uh
i think he fought last time he fought he
fought uh
so he's not even ranked
okay hey was the last time she'll fought
before this shogun
oh
yeah osp for sure yeah for sure
oh split decision right that's where i
go damn oops
well
it's all right hopefully it'll be next
we'll be a little more exciting paul
craig
2020
oh
yeah he's been fighting man uh-oh
i don't know man he had a couple fights
in the 2020. man he looked like greg
don't he look like greg
greg jones yeah dwight
yo sorry about that hey so uh brendan's
not here because he's on tour right now
but we have a clip from his special the
gringo poppy let's take a look
i'm the only person in my house who
don't speak spanish
i feel like a refugee in my own goddamn
house
my white friends aren't a latina before
go dude just [ __ ] learn spanish put a
little effort in and learn spanish how
hard can it be i'm all [ __ ] i am 38.
i struggle with english at times
you know what it feels like to my
five-year-old son roll up on his bike
and talk [ __ ] to me in spanish you know
what that feels like as a father you
know what that feels like
i don't have a clue what he's talking
about i have a clue
i thought puto met dude for the longest
time
i dropped another school last week i was
all later pluto
teacher was like what the [ __ ] am i
putto pluto
[Music]
pluto
what's up fellas i miss you guys so i
can't be there hopefully it's going
pretty good rashad what's up dude
rampage i'll let you boy
looking good my man
vitreon real chatty as usual good to see
you guys man listen this important
message i'm taking a break for a reason
yeah i'm not there right now but this is
a special message for you guys not the
three of you and the staff just maybe
this might help you that's just for the
fans watching calabasas fight company
without me right now hope you guys enjoy
in the fights because this man stress
shows up in all kinds of ways yep and in
a world that's telling you do more sleep
less grind all the time
you've heard it from pete did i sleep
three hours a day do ya do ya listen
here's a reminder to take care of
yourself we don't talk about enough men
take care of yourself do less maybe try
some therapy how about that all right
yeah i'm stressed out my special just
dropped it's pretty stressful i'm
grinding my teeth i'm not eating as much
i'm not sleeping great i need some help
man can't keep talking to you three this
isn't helping i'm looking at you matt
it's not helping dude i appreciate the
help it's not helping you know what
helps better help it's customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to but you can
you can also do that it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy give
it a try and see if online therapy can
help lower your stress this episode of
the cowbest fight campaign without me is
brought to you by better help and the
calabasas fight companion listeners and
viewers you get ten percent off your
first month at betterhelp.com
that's better help b e t t e r h e l p
dot com
shop all right get 10 off take a chance
trust me it's worth it
i care about you i care about all you
guys watching this right now rashad miss
you buddy rampage
chin in the back
matrione betterhelp.com
all right
dot com
shop let's get back
to listen to these three
listen man i can't i can't get upset
my meatloaf is so damn good
these boys like hey
mom the meatloaf i need the meatloaf
they rashad went over there the meatloaf
is so good we're shouting over there
just to watch joe eat my meatloaf
i mean that's how things happen
sometimes listen i might sell the recipe
someday i mean i got i got some secrets
you know i got some secrets joe i threw
down in the kitchen today i had no idea
that you were such a chef
i mean i was unaware i didn't i don't
think anybody had my chicken though i
don't think anybody had a chicken yet at
least i didn't have it yet i didn't have
your chicken yet yeah anyway you wanna
know what i did with the chicken today
i'm gonna let you on a little secret i'm
gonna take you to church a little bit
right now joe okay
i took the chicken right
i split the skin and and the breast so i
split it up
so i separated it and then i took a
peach habanero driver you took the skin
off no no no no no you just separated it
so i put my hand in there uh it kind of
looked like pan's labyrinth that looked
all weird going through the skin but
like um
then i um
all right hey so we got to talk about
this real quick uh michael chandler vs
tony ferguson who pulls it down
man i like ferguson i like ferguson i
mean i i like both of them i just i want
to see i don't know i always wanted i
want to see the guy
come back and do the thing and i feel
like there's a lot uh
a lot of people doubting him so i kind
of want that okay and i like how weird
he is i think he's cool he's so weird
dude he's so weird his uh
striking off his back the the
submissions that he goes for he's an
entertaining dude when's the last time
he fought it's been a hot minute right
uh he lost the gaichi yeah yeah yeah
kind of broken well that was a long time
ago though that was like a two years
after that though did he because he tore
two acls like had title shots and lost
those oh he felt he fought a delarus and
got uh heel hooks remember yeah but he
got hit hooked yeah yeah he's been on a
three fight losing streak oh that's not
good at all yeah so this is this so this
is the problem right here what's the uh
what's that that is a problem
18. wow that is i mean that is a little
bit of stretch um but i mean i mean the
child's on the vera fight yeah i
remember how brutal that fight was it
was the unanimous decision but the
brutality that was displayed in that
fight
was career changing like sometimes
you can lose a fight
and get knocked out and get beat and
still be saved as a fighter like your
career
but if you stay in a fight too long as a
fighter and get beat up for five rounds
you could be done as a fighter well it's
like uh the whittaker and uh
you know romero fight they had two back
to back and it was like that and like
whitaker wasn't the same for a while
after that you know yeah
he was like you think that's
was tough too
so he had three of them now and that was
and that was beneal devroosh's like
coming out party that one yeah you know
what i'm saying so
he's been on a tough skit i mean look at
all of them cerrone pettis kevin lee i
mean he's supposed to be i mean they're
all they're all named
this right here is just like this
i
tony
tony
before all like the hot the habib
you know what i'm saying all the fight
they couldn't get together with them
like before that tony was like one of
the best guys like like like i'll i
watch him fight i'm like yo i watched
him fight live edson barbosa and it was
just oh he put the pressure on that that
was it was just it was just beautiful it
was like a really beautiful fight and
i'm just like yo this dude he's he he
was just nasty at that point and i feel
like tony ferguson at that level was the
best in the world but then he kept
you know he'd be on the shelf for too
long and he wasn't consistent in
competing and then it just took his toll
oh so i'm going to give you something
that oh yeah here's two year break oh
yeah
so uh
all right you're probably not going to
agree with this assessment of mine but
you are absolutely right that tony
ferguson whooped edson barbosa's ass and
he put pressure on the whole time and
got after him right yeah but
the reason that that happened in my
perspective is because they fought in a
small cage and and and edson
notoriously does not fight one of small
cases he's a movement fighter and on top
of that tony wants to have that small
pressure because he likes he likes all
the pressure he wants a small cage and
he feels comfortable there so same thing
that like so i think he was able to make
such a statement against barbosa because
he had a smaller area didn't have to
chase him down as much and could really
put on a show with nothing i think in
the big cage i think michael chandler uh
outshines him
oh yeah i mean well tonight i mean he's
such a different fighter since when you
fought heads in barbosa like
that was those were miles and miles ago
we got a lot of
miles over the speedometer since that
cool but i mean
i feel like chandler when you look at
chandler you know his story making a
splash coming from bellator that's
awesome the way he did you know uh
coming in and putting that putting the
spotlight on himself yeah you know
owning that bull's eye 100 and uh going
out there and fighting the way he has
fought it's crazy because
you'll see him in training he's so
professional like he's professional you
know he comes there and he has
everything uh you know everything in
order you know no his bag is not in
disarray he comes in he does his you
know his warm up the same way very
professionally he's got his tools that
he uses to warm up and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying like for me i was just
like yeah yeah that's it i'm god that's
good gucci you know yeah but he's a
professional about his stuff man
and uh
the growth that he's been able to have
underneath henry hooves for sure you
know what i'm saying is just different
and his in his athleticism you see his
workouts yes man i've been watching him
on ig i'm just like wow you'd be really
doing backflips holding a [ __ ]
yeah like you know what i'm saying oh
yeah medicine ball what yeah dude come
on man i trained at his gym in nashville
one time and i was like just seeing just
seeing the setup like i walked down i
was like wow this dude really must mean
it because there's some really weird
[ __ ] in here and like like this dude and
you know what he means it like you know
he uses all that stuff
for sure like he and i'll take this much
he also works tirelessly like that dude
works plus being like coming from
bellator and being the top guy at
bellator and everyone's saying like
you're not at that level you're not at
that level then he comes over from that
and bam he's obviously at this level do
you remember do you remember watching
those videos of the flow wrestling
between him and marty
what's that do you remember watching the
the flow wrestling videos like just in
practice and they were just flowing and
those two those two him and marty uh
usman camaro were just
flowing in a way that was so athletic it
was like it was like poetry i don't like
wrestling but it was like poetry and
wrestling and they were just funny yeah
because like they they know how to do
that like a nice randori where like it's
a give and take you know what i'm saying
and you know which one is giving take as
a dance it's really a dance like a you
know like a dance and then they're doing
like these nice ass moves these nice
aerials but they're training their body
to have like this this reaction time you
know and you do it for fun but
your fun becomes you know what your body
gets used to just in case you have to
pull it out in a real situation
and they do they were fluid in this
thing i mean i'm talking about like
it was incredible and like for me i hit
the ground i'm on the ground for a half
for a second and a half like i remember
to go move these things these cats were
just
[Music]
and both like him and marty are so
accomplished as far as like like
wrestling ability it was great to watch
man
not as fun as watching uh uh overeem and
uh tyrone's phone go at it but it was
pretty dope though who won that round
he won that round we won that round was
talking about it
dang tony look older though man he does
he's definitely i don't want to say i
don't want to say it man but
that great man is popping man he should
adjust for me just a little bit put a
little shoe polish in him just a little
bit it makes you feel good you got to
sometimes put that carlos boozer in
there real quick you can't look he's
looking across the cage you see all that
gray you know i'm saying he's like i'm
gonna get this old man up out of here
that's what he's saying
hey you know when i first met randy
randy was probably
50
and randy kicked my ass for about for
about three hours of practice yeah oh my
god randy couture gotta hold me one time
in practice beat me like i stole
something yeah randy got me too man
randy says randy's getting me all the
time and it just his pressure was
ridiculous and he never got tired how
well he pummeled yo and he he'll like
want to go like an hour ago
yeah yeah
dude do you know how long he warms up
before a fight he warms up for like like
an hour hour and a half yeah like he
warms up
being his partner for an hour straight
yeah he's going i've heard him uh
stories about him after he after his
weigh-ins as soon as he rehydrates he
goes and does another workout to sweat
him back yo he yo
before he goes to bed then before the
fight unreal okay he's on it's on his
own this joint got me excited man
see if anything tells me that
tony is gonna get caught is that little
pun that pause that he do it's not it's
not good like he pauses awkward there
but then tony's got a big reach
advantage and tony will lump you up you
know i really love you all right
uh cowboy remember cowboy's whole eye
got all swell up was that when he blew
his nose and it popped up i mean he does
damage he's got that front kick he
throws away yeah yeah i'm telling you
guys
and you see the way he comes off at
those angles too like he can hit with
any side he's got his own rhythm you
know nobody's gonna gonna move like him
you know when i see his i hate oh that
hurts that hurt right you know when i
see his body who it reminds me of i'll
say christian machinist who christian
bale and the machinist
it's just like
something about him makes me think of
that
tony's sticking him right now
but he got one of those bodies
like if you see him on the street she's
like oh then i'll message oh [ __ ]
tony is tired of disrespect bro that's a
lot of salt in his pepper wow that's a
lot that's what i was saying man hey
like he looks like he when he's not
training he's a scarecrow
i mean that's a long way for uh a lot of
distance for uh from michael to cover
chandler to try to cover it when he's
talking about you know what he's trying
to grapple with he's telling you he's
thumping him oh he got him oh that hurt
him that left hook on the way out got
him though he had him look
watching him
now be careful
he's falling he landed solid right on
his liver twice oh god i could have
heard if you threw it with some intent
that's a good look okay boy tony
i remember when i was i saw michael when
he first started training was over at
randy's gym and i was like who's this
little tiny with all the muscles right
spandex
and then turned out to be michael
chandler man my chest is hurting a
little bit i'm
oh oh oh god left foot caught you caught
him caught him again they caught him on
the way out mandy caught uh channel on
the way out
solve the riddle buddy oh man oh man i
gotta be careful and chandler's not like
you know that's a lot of distance cover
right there for sure he's getting back
down he's getting back down he just
keeps putting the numbers out there
just keep putting the numbers out there
man the time yeah oh yeah wow that's
good that's a hell of a shot
just saying this ain't a rest area
though just not around no it's not
got to get his arm up though he's got to
get his arm
there you go challenge
yeah you're talking about his strikes in
the box dude his elbows from the bottom
are nasty
and they've got the scarecrow
oh tony it's nasty oh chandler breed
oh my gosh tony is a monster you know
one reason i'm glad i wasn't arrested
because my knees get all torn up from
the canvas
is that michael bleeding like that yeah
yeah
telling you he's everything he's thrown
has landed pretty much yo this dude is a
monster he came out and landed like a
five piece that's what i said man he's
sticking him right before and then he
dropped his ass
wow oh
super effective good job covering your
face up oh he's just i thought he's got
a get caught on the platter right there
i know what's so impressive though is
just how chandler is
staying in yeah staying in there like
yeah that's a that's a lot of that's a
lot of muscle control on michael's part
oh no
oh thank god if he gets all that
toes
but it lets you know like how vulnerable
that heals feeling on his feet if he
chooses this as a lesson
i'm saying like if this is a lesser of
two evils holy that means a whole lot
yeah that's that's saying a lot for what
he was feeling on his feet yeah he
hasn't lumped up and and yeah and that
tony's so dangerous over time on the
ground he's proven that time and time
again yeah so yeah you're choosing going
to lion's den just so you don't get
touched up
but now this gives tony a lot of
confidence in his run because look he
already touched him he knows that he can
get him on the feet but not only that
he's working him on the ground and
michael can't transition anywhere yeah
he's he's feeling that chandler's
getting
getting close he's got to be feeling
that yeah he's getting clingy he's
getting desperate oh oh
challenge is so strong though the
channel is so strong but the muscles
they got to breathe right they got to
breathe
i don't know that's a good mother rashad
do you like playing mouth cover games
like if you're on the ground yeah man
yeah uh-huh controllers
i like i like
like sometimes you got to make them
think
like that it's not even about just
just scoring you're going to suffer
that's just making them like you're
going to suffer you know what i'm saying
like you got to do that
and that's one of the yeah because
because that that makes them want to get
out of there right everything is
building up to making them want to get
out of there so sometimes you just got
to just grind your forearm right in
their face
i think that uh look at happy tony
standing up oh oh oh
back in his ass oh
yo chandler's gotta be so scared right
now like not scared but just like in his
and it's like oh [ __ ] like hey he's he's
tony's sick tony's got issues took him
down and now i'm getting [ __ ] up and
when they stood up one of his faces all
purple from not being able to breathe
and it wasn't tony yo his right eye too
look at chandler's right eye when they
show him on camera
it's lumped up
[Music]
oh that was a good two-piece
what's el cacoo is that the boogie man
yeah
yeah
hey man
that's a good shot though that's a
powerful shot are you trying to jump out
of that or was that michael doing that
that was michael doing that man that's a
flare that's that's [ __ ]
backflips with a dead
medicine ball that's what that is that's
what that is
[Laughter]
oh wow he is lumped up yeah that right
eye man wow
have you been injured in the fight
before like in the fight you got injured
yeah what happened when i fought sam
holger i used to be up so blind i needed
i needed glasses but i didn't wear them
in this fight
oh my god
oh my god please oh oh my god
cheated him
turn tony over man oh my god
oh holy [ __ ] oh my god oh
four of them
wow
oh my god
oh hey dude holy [ __ ] wow
i love this sport so much wow
he's got so much power he doesn't see
that oh you didn't see it did you guys
it was a kick to his face he got me
cheated bro no it wasn't a kick yeah and
it was out of nowhere yeah i thought it
was a right hand no he was a kick
oh my god you're completely out i didn't
look at that big old fella i knew that
fall was different
oh my god right here in the chat is he
is he awake yet that's what's scary i
don't know that was a scary one yeah
you know what i caught him here looked
like it looked like they caught him his
cheekbone
i mean he didn't catch me in his mouth
like vitoria i thought it hit him this
way
oh it might have it might have been like
that
holy good lord okay replay yeah for real
man show us the longest
what are they doing why they keep it
suspicious
announce the winner and go man
good job michael they're letting him
have his moment though he letting him
have his moment
he got a new song you see you got a new
son they adopted a new one did they
really yeah they got another baby boy
man good for them man yeah how's it
going
there you go there you go there's this
baby
there's hat he got another son
oh that's a beautiful thing
oh i love you daddy oh man i'm gonna cry
man
that's great here we go i knew it was
overhand right man y'all saying it was a
kick
he has a kick bro oh
i didn't realize it got him right there
dude holy gee
christmas bro wow
that was like a boot stomp like uh oh
good job michael for not killing him
again
yeah
straight up
oh my gosh
dude that caused some damage man yeah
because think about that that's
retirement that i did towards the
brainstem yeah that's retirement because
daniel missed it i think daniel missed
it
yeah dave was like me
look at this right here what an athlete
this is an athlete right here man dude
michael chandler's truth yo he's
indifferent
god dang oh he's up he's out what
happened what happened i was fine
damn he was having so much fun too dude
yeah dude that hey that was stressful
there's no um there's no other sport on
earth
that can make that response
there's none that can make you go from
watching and stressed out to being oh my
god doing backflips dude but but that
transition was crazy or right from
thinking about that he was looking like
in the corner channel was like oh my god
i gotta go out with this monster who was
giving me momentum who's gaining
momentum then he put his lights out like
that dude they said his wife makes more
money than michael
oh yeah she's a doctor right yeah she
pulls down coins son really
it's good for him yeah
good for michael i'm really happy that's
beautiful man
i'm so happy for him man he's a good
dude too man really good dude yeah
and he helps people he makes people
better yeah man like he's not like one
of those is just really good whatever he
does like he makes everybody else but he
he comes in does actually work with a
bunch of other people yeah yeah
good for him good for him
hell yeah hey man that's funny dude like
the sport
god damn
sport bro
wow man that's beautiful man good for
that man
and that chicken is kind of nice though
what's that fruit right there
huh what's that fruit
that right there let me see it that's
you ready for something yeah right
oh that's your passion
pineapple that looks great
god that is dirty wow
man
man
look at his neck
oh man
oh my god
that's instant out instant
dude he was doing so good too
yeah he was doing it was really good he
was doing so good man awesome
isn't that absolutely amazing man
good
chandler's the truth
love
well he's got a lot he's got a lot of
tools on toolbox right
it seems like he used them
whoa you can rip a promo too
it looks like
i might wish i could hear this i don't
know
do people still care
kind of paycheck
look at joe joe's so happy
mcgregor at 170. mcgregor 170.
hey he's a beast on a mic huh god
that didn't work
that was probably just as good as mute
as it would have been
for sure
i didn't need to hear a word yeah i
totally understand this
he wants to fight somebody quickly
that's what he said
golly yo he just yo he is a man y'all
good for him good for them good for
their family too oh yeah
buddy
yo
all right gentlemen once again i gotta
talk to you about my beautiful happy
hippo products let's go hey man listen i
use kratom today didn't use any time
before but i use it today and my brain
was off the charts today i feel like i'm
the smartest dude on the planet
definitely the smartest dude in the room
it is the best pro focused product that
brendan ever talks about it's the best
product i've used today and let me tell
you for the best part it's all natural
visit
happyhippoherbles.com i didn't say happy
hippo herbals i said happyhippo
herbals.com use the promo code thickboy
that's a triple c thick boy for 20 off
for life son use that code as many times
you want that means you have to order a
whole bunch of times you can't just use
it all many times you want just use it
once let's get up let's get weird let's
do it happy hippo herbals.com make your
brain turn limitless let's get weird
let's get weird
i mean listen
i mean listen i i'm going to
congratulate myself i might lose my
breath and slap myself in the back too
hard but i kind of went hard on the
grill today
i kind of did some things today sure
look like you did something i didn't do
these ones though i should i don't feel
like i bet what kind of house was that i
didn't i didn't cook for my friend
that's all good man you know what i'm
saying you brought me to this world
this fight this fight though who we got
i always got rose man i always got rose
damn she has 42 takedowns and how many
fights carla's a beast a beast bro yeah
a beast for real
well
i still just got to go hey by the way
now we're talking about rose
i gotta talk to about sean strickland
i'm really salty sean i don't know who
you are and to be honest with you i
don't even think i've ever watched you
fight but i'm gonna be really honest
with you
you're talking about some [ __ ] you don't
know what you're talking about with this
whole thing about pat berry and rose and
you're calling trying to call pat of
predator and blah blah blah
i was there i was at duke rufus's gym
when rose was 17 years old i was there
on her 18th birthday i was there for the
conversation that rose had with me it
was like hey how do you think pat feels
about this situation i'm turning that
team to my own i want to ask him to date
i love who he is i love his energy i
love how excited he is i think he's a
great human being and rose knew from the
jump from the jump that pat was gonna be
somebody that was in her life forever
and ever so for you to run your mouth
talking about whatever kind of [ __ ]
you're talking about calling my good
buddy pat a predator when you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about that
really kind of bothers me a little bit
so
listen man i understand you're trying to
get some attention trying to get some
some burn trying to get a little bit of
attention and
and whatever you got to get
but
talk about proper things when you know
what you're talking about you what
you're talking about in this one you
just call this one square son leave this
one alone you're barking up the wrong
tree
and that's all i got to say about that
damn you went there you went there i had
to it wasn't right the whole thing's
about it's about a situation that was a
misunderstanding was a misquote about
what when bro said she met pat when she
was 14. she did that's when she met him
at duke rufus's gym doesn't mean [ __ ]
by the way how about talking about
opportunities right those kids that get
on on the uh the main card when cerrone
went out yeah how about daniel cormier
being a
last minute replacement for a
heavyweight tournament and then turned
into daniel freaking cormier yo
i mean you see seizure moment champion
yeah that's spaghetti on your sweater
already for sure
oh this is amazing
oh they're going to do dc i told you i'm
smarter than you in the room i think
it's dc hall of fame moment
oh is it really i think so
dc man
he deserves it we have beers just dc
hall of fame mama
you say beers you want beer what do you
want
hey can we get a beer please that bag is
right by you
oh we got beers right here son
you want a bottle that's all we've got
about it there's whiskey burning
whiskey's right there too if you guys
want it
oh you know what i haven't drank a
single thing this whole time no that's
what i'm saying i mean let's get weird
joe i mean listen just because we're
being sober with rashad doesn't mean we
have to be sober with rashad you need to
open up that
oh [ __ ]
do it careful teeth break them break it
no
do it no
come on baby we have openers here not
going to work
but the first time when i was a kid i
learned how to open up uh
[Music]
oh nice get your amateur ass out of here
son
i learned how to open up
seat belt
um we just got these ones you want to
try it you ever had it i want a big ipa
guy
i don't know try it out let's see if you
like if you don't like it i'll drink it
we have truly's too or seltzers joe is
definitely a truly guy he's been truly a
guy a long time
i'll take this one that's what i'm
saying
but this is amazing though man but they
knew it right like it's not a surprise
to him no i think it's a surprise but
why she gonna be crying they do that
sometimes they surprise him yes i'm
surprised this surprise when he did it
for me
that's so dope that is so dope
there's nobody more deserving he's such
a good he's such a good dude man
like there's not many people that that
really can toe the line of being jovial
yet of being such a full-on badass yeah
and he is that human being
yeah man that's an amazing moment for dc
shall i look forward to being there for
yours buddy
you look forward to being there for mike
what happened
it's already happening it's already
happening i know it dude
i was like uh i don't know
i was like i don't think he knows yet
guys what is it what what are the
benefits of being in the whole thing
i mean look at this it's just a minute
it's just just a beautiful moment it's
just a recognition you know what i'm
saying like
you fight as an athlete and uh you know
you you
you don't know how it's going to be
received and just to know what you mean
to other people and just see how they
appreciate you that's where you feel
like
damn it was more than just about
fighting
dude he's such a good human being such a
good dad look at this moment man look at
this
how dope
look at it
oh look at dominic cruz
that would be really hard to go back
into something like that you know like
all right guys so
so next up
that's emotional looking at me crying
man
wow oh man that's good for dc man
attaboy
yeah he deserves that man he deserves
that
and he's so eloquent too man you know
like he speaks so well so like he's able
to communicate
complex feelings well and fluidly
yeah man yeah he's a [ __ ] stud he's
so fluid up there too
yeah that dude really sees the moment
man he really did yeah
he sees the cars going
yeah
but they get they gave him this time to
look at him again this time
yeah joe was crying a little bit i see a
little eyes yeah watering joe's feeling
that
that's so dope and that's so dope they
did that surprise too man yeah man they
got on here you know
what's your relationship with dana
are we cool man yeah we cool man me too
i got asked about them the other day
like hey man like blah blah blah like
what's santa white and i was like you
know what
he's a businessman but i have a good
relationship with him like even like
after everything that that my career has
been then every time i see danny is real
cool and i guarantee if i had to call
him up and be like hey man i need a
little something here he'd people go let
me see how i can help you out yeah yeah
dan is a good dude man yeah dan is a
good dude he's straight up you know what
i'm saying yeah you know where you stand
that's it yeah yeah yeah rather rather
whether it's good or bad he's gonna tell
you you know what i'm saying yeah so it
is
that's that's what i appreciate about uh
me and dana's relationship it wasn't
always like
good at all like we would get into
arguments and stuff like i would say
not arguments but we'll go back and
forth in the media you know what i'm
saying
and uh you know we just
finally got to a point in our
relationship where we just
we just
just talked to each other you know yeah
and uh we just always
you know we we have that
a good relationship since tough like
when i first met dana white on tough uh
oh he wasn't a fan of heroes huh
well he so
he almost didn't let me on the show
because i was too small and he made a
comment like he's like bro i got [ __ ]
guys so big they got a [ __ ] duck to
get through the [ __ ] door what's
gonna happen you're gonna get on my
[ __ ] show you're gonna get taken down
and i'm gonna have a boring episode
cause you're [ __ ] too little to get
off your back and i was like oh [ __ ]
that was the interview to get on top so
but i finessed my way to get on there
but uh
yeah we were cool after that did you
beef up for that did you try to eat as
much as you possibly could yeah man just
[ __ ]
a lot of a lot of mashed potatoes and
stuff like that yeah
a lot of mashed potatoes i was working
at the hospital at the time and you were
a guard right yeah security that's a
while and the lunch lady was like my
home girl so she'll like give me like
all like the
the hospital you know hospital food for
sure yeah yeah so i was eating hospital
food starchy food every single night i
hate eating after the point
joe how old were you when you got your
first title
oh 20
i don't know
what did i turn
uh that's probably like 22 23 yeah
sound like you can start taking those uh
notes
[Laughter]
man
hey who do you like on this one right
here
gross questions i mean i like rose but i
think carlos sports is badass too though
no i think carla's definitely a game
issue and i guess that she beat her in
the
yeah
yeah so she knows how to fight her she
got that experience she's got that that
positive reinforcement in her mind to go
back to you know what i'm saying how
many rematches have you stationed
uh just the one for tito ortiz yeah and
when you smoked them yeah
how did you lose here the first time it
was a draw i didn't lose something it
was a draw yeah was it weird was it was
having a rematch weird for you
nah not really no
it was it was actually like
it made me feel more comfortable than
anything yeah yeah because you had a
familiarity yeah yeah like the the most
the most the hardest part is
when you're
getting ready to fight somebody else
just the anticipation of what they feel
like you know once
you know what they feel like you're like
all right cool i know yeah you know yeah
i know what i need to do
takes like the anxiousness off you
already know you already know it's going
to be i felt that when i fought cyber
marcus we had we fought three times
it's like a familiarity but you can like
yeah definitely feel it's different yeah
it's different it's different
okay
so we're talking about kickboxing
um he's accomplished for sure
but for some reason i just can't get on
the bandwagon who
i forgot his name raymond
raymond raymond daniels raymond daniels
man i i wasn't i mean i tried to fight
it he's good he's really good highlight
reel it's like a karate style yeah he's
got a little
something about him that's what i'm
saying
it's not like us i want to like him
because he's so efficient but something
about him is like i just i just can't
get on the bandwagon i don't know it's
hard not to like it like she's feeling
like a staff no no
i just i don't see
how it's so effective i really don't
like
but it is and it's against the best in
the world and it's not like freaking 720
punches yeah yeah oh dude and like and i
see it and it's like
what's this because it's it's a standard
face
that he has though and his liver kick oh
my god he's got uh it's kind of a
similar style to uh
wonderboy sideways yeah
they cover so much more so much
farther distance than you ever think
they could yeah that sideways stance
dude wonderboy's had a heck of a career
and he's barely taking a beating that
dude just kind of skates in if he loses
he lose by points and it's just because
like nobody couldn't get in on somebody
but he really he's taken almost no
beating for a long long time
he's found a way to kind of reinvent
himself
in the later part of his career and
that's and that's the key thing that
like adapting yourself and your fight
game to the later half of your career a
lot of fighters can't do it but if you
can do it you can make it be successful
like dan henderson yeah yeah i'm saying
like randy couture they found out a very
good way to use their skill set in the
later after years you know
well if you think about that if like if
you're going to talk about using a skill
set that you never showed before
you're going to talk about keratin off
against tyrone spawn yeah dude that's
like he who knew that he even knew how
to do what he did there
like i didn't expect that at all
tyrone didn't either that was a hard
fight man
it was a hard fight man
it was yeah like who saw it coming nah i
know
i know
do i he's he's such a stoic russian i
kicked that dude
i felt like i kicked him in the stomach
probably 87 times in one round and like
i was like how is this dude not folding
over your reaction but you gotta see the
way this dude is like
i didn't really
appreciate his size he's until like
you're up he's close to him because he's
he's he's like shrek like if shrek was a
human being he'd be built like him he's
like a he's like an older like he's got
that like dense thick bones like
skull right his head is huge how big is
his head
and you you know you got it i got a dope
yo yo
yo you're saying shrek and i'm like
it makes his head look like it's a
normal sized head
it's a thick ass head too yeah it's a
big-ass block and like and it sits on a
no neck to just show on shoulders no
neck just sure
can you imagine that you know and like
and he doesn't look like you have muscle
he's just just girthy like yeah
yeah
and you're like you see him getting just
on top
like like it was it was weird like
watching him fight because like one was
like fighting him because like he he was
a dude like
he's if he's going to lose
he has one punch power and he knows it
so he can just take a beating but just
drop this one thing and everything's
different like roy roy nelson was
getting out on him and then he had wore
the jab
and then it completely changed the fight
like he beat he he he slept roy in a
dirty way same honestly same way not he
he knocked me out
um
and was so efficient at it
but that jab was the hardest thing i've
ever been hit by
not in practice
she's looking gross i'm always
interested to see
how rose come out right i'm always
interested to see like
what her mind said like she wears it on
her face you know i'm saying you can
tell
where she's at
but t does such a good job trevor does
such a good job of dialing them in you
know
trevor is a um is a very positive coach
very positive hell dude he's thinking
with his three main people right yeah
like uh marty rosen and uh gaithy yeah
how can they be any better than what
they're being right now they i mean
they're killing it
that little fella back there dancing
that's chico camus he fought in the
ocean for a little while too
don't get them rose
i don't even mean to be like i don't i
don't i honestly don't know anything
about carlos carla espaza suppose she
trains in uh
out here in l.a and uh irvine that's you
mm-hmm with team oyama yeah
she's gotten a lot better man she's
gotten a lot better but yeah for a long
time too yeah
she's growing like the her
like since she
like she got she she was afraid at one
point i remember when she fought like
joanna young
remember when she walked down she looked
so afraid you know rose no not rose i'm
talking about uh asparagus she's very
afraid
and then like for a few fights after
that when she fought it looked like she
was kind of scared you know but then all
of a sudden like she just like changed
she started to change up you know
adapting her game like i'm not saying
that she was scared but like you know
she had that look in the eyes like she
was
easy to discourage you know what i'm
saying like you know when you fight the
guy and he looks like he's in there but
like
it's that fake confidence like you know
if you slap him hard he's gonna be like
he wants a way out you know what i'm
saying she had a look in her eyes from
1906
yeah she's got a lot of experience yeah
yeah i mean that suit jacket though yo
bruce be coming through with this yo
who's comfortable with the suit jacket
this is what i want and they're like
yo bruce does everything the most
extravagant i remember one time
uh
i was at a fight i had a fight party at
like i think one of the clubs there in
vegas
and uh bruce walked in with like a harem
of
a harem yes of women like 17 of the
baddest women you ever want to see and
just had a table with just him there
just with all these girls it was just
like okay bruce
it's extravagance extravagance
hell yeah bruce
every time i see him in vegas he's
always like living his life yeah man oh
for sure living it oh he's he's got the
game figured out crazy
crazy jacket on and uh yeah
he was telling me he's got his big
octagon ring you've
there's like this
huge uh ufc octagon like ring that's
pretty good
bruce is funny man shall you want
something to drink man you want some
water or anything yeah yeah i've been
thirsty the whole time
hey can we get you out of water or
something i ain't got nothing to drink
anything else yeah you know what let me
get one of those uh
what what are those um
like the lacora like the the sparkling
water ones remember the one we got
lacroix not the ones we got from the
store uh
there you go sorry those are right here
i guess cherry you got those
you drink those things yeah there's no
there's no soda it's not soda just
flavored water yeah you drink you drink
like sparkly water bubbly water yeah
you're boozy man
you're different you're different now
you changed money doesn't change yeah
this is this this is this i was trying
to quote the rest of that drake song but
i couldn't pull it up
without life without it would go i
couldn't remember it
yeah now i'll drink celery
that's your flavor that's my that's my
joint it's like
oh that's that girl
right now that one hit and it's like
whoa missed it there you go thug rose i
see you buddy
i do the feminist hell yeah
oh man look at rose
come on bro god how do you not love me
come on rose bros i love rose come on
thug rose
come on rose you got this dude it's
funny like she was literally she was
like that one she was
15 16 17 years old she was just like
that
you go carla yeah
you went for what's his name too
tony so you keep going with your people
yeah you know
that's funny they're so small that ring
looks so big with them you get heavy
weights in there they take two steps so
we're right in the middle right
those little things can bounce around
like guard they go behind that ring yes
for them right right it's like fighting
the parking lot that's massive for them
you know
oh shit's a five rounder huh
we might be here all night
yeah championship fight no i think won
five rounds
i bet there's gonna be one hell of a
filling out process just because they
know each other a little bit so they're
just gonna kind of wait be patient oh
look at rose let's see look how smooth
she looks on face
see that [ __ ]
rose is another one that hasn't taken
much either well you can already tell by
the wide stance that rose is getting
ready for a shot
you think so yeah because if she was
worried about kicks you wouldn't have
that wide of a stance you know when
you're going somebody who's going to
kick you you narrow up your stance she's
getting ready to kick
well when she gets ready to kick then
she's narrowing up the chance that she
is right now but when she's on the
defense you'll notice how how wide her
legs get yeah
she's mobile though she's on her bike
for sure she's not trying to sit around
there
here come the cape
there's a
esparza does she finish a lot of fights
or she kind of uh nah she she got a wall
install like a ground stall she yeah
she's a grinder she's a grinder
and she's good at the gate oh i see you
i love watching athleticism you know
roses yeah rose rosen got
she's a master that movement you know
that's the thing that trevor that
separates trevor from all the other
coaches yeah
that i work with he really makes you
work on these angles and movements and
he's got a different way of boxing i
mean about about moving because he's
learned how to adapt his boxing movement
to mma you know because sometimes you
use boxing movement but then it's not
good as far as range-wise for mma so
he's still vulnerable but he's really
found a way to adapt the boxing movement
to mma
you know he he those onyx loves are good
gloves man oh man the one he makes those
are those arguably those might be the
best gloves in the game right now the
honest clothes are the best clothes man
dude they're really good you can wear
those gloves without having your hands
wrapped or nothing and just kind of put
them on kojaks and just be all right
yeah yeah they're nice man they're
really you know you can't go cold jacks
up in any any kind of gloves so you
can't not i'm gonna hit hard no not not
a lot of them you mess around and uh
break your hands for your little baby
hands maybe i got grown man hands
uh-oh
see i'm surprised that you're gonna wrap
my hands over
i love these things
these
things like bricks
i'm surprised roe's not touching him
over that jab you know
but you know what though here's here
even with the jab though she's jabbing
too high she should be jabbing to the
body it should be to the body she should
be jabbing right to the chest so that
way
when uh carla feels that pressure she's
gonna lower her level and go right into
that jab you know right so you see what
i'm saying about taking a shot yeah so
like all like rose needs to be jabbing
to the chest not jabbing to her face but
jabbing to her chest
that's a whole i do this really barely
been it's been a lot dancing huh
told you to be long feeling out process
yeah i didn't see that coming though
i wanted they're booing yet
you know oh dude that's a good job just
stuck with the jab yeah it was long too
she kept it straight
she carries a distance so well man she
carries she looks so smooth
yeah she's
slick and like it's funny like she can
casual oh that was a good check hook she
can casually move so well like it's it's
gotta be so frustrating for a car uh for
a spaza
like how do you hit what you can't even
come close to smelling
and she's so like she's so long
and she knows how to fight
long and and and low and stuff like this
so it's
look at that
i mean see the way she just stepped off
there and then i suppose i had no idea
what to do so just bailed out yeah yeah
and rosie's just playing just trying to
find an angle yeah she's seeing it she's
right now i'm just recording
recording movement
what's she gonna do if i do this okay
she does that i'm gonna do it again okay
she does that again
that's what you gotta do just start
clocking right now she's clocking her
i mean it's hard to call car to talk
anything about this fight but [ __ ] i
mean it was it was still athletic i mean
was that a draw is that nine nine-nine
yeah how's it gonna go
i was talking to pat a little video and
pat said that pretty much all he does is
work with rose like he holds pads with
rose that's a little better he's kind of
like her coach like obviously trevor and
uh the dude from minnesota is too but
for the most part what's that dude's
name greg
minnesota was uh brock's coach
who greg
he was brock's coach he's the other guy
the guy with the blonde hair back there
uh the quiet guy whoever talks greg
nelson that's oh hell yeah joe i see
you've been taking your happy horrible
song yeah what i'm saying this happy hip
hop happy hippo yeah i'm saying i'm
happy hippo happy hippos in the
commercials the one jab that landed lit
lit her whole forehead up
i don't know no
boy you know sometimes these girls get
hit in the head they'd be looking like
right remember how joanna was at one
time
[Music]
well johanna's head was messed up after
that though
i love watching you oh yeah what she was
getting was it
she look like you cut her skull and then
that hurt because
i heard you see my girl you wanted like
that man i love you anna man yo is she
i'm just saying she's still fighting
yeah she's fighting yeah she gotta
she'll fight willy again i think yeah
does she and yeah that's one how do you
say her name
julie exactly
that girl was phenomenal too oh man and
now that she's with henry
she's with henry henry who don't henry
kennedy kind of brought a little nasty
inside in there and now that she's lost
she's got like a little nasty edge tour
you know what i'm saying like
it's such a yeah this is gonna be such a
frustrating fight for both striking's on
like another level yeah i believe yeah
oh dude she's not pumped yeah she is
she's uh i do i was really surprised
when rose caught that i didn't and she
beat her twice right yeah like i was
really surprised super suppressed yeah
man
like um and then like bro bros when she
took her down what what in the fifth
round right because she had to was two
two if rose didn't take her down she
might have lost that fight but she did a
hell of a job by getting her down and
just controlling her
that's probably why she went to
henry
probably
yeah got that rose bug now she's worried
about it yeah yeah before that it was
joanna she was worried about she got her
striking off ridiculous right oh here's
on the shot come and go oh wow good job
oh good job rose good job
okay shot are you as a wrestler yeah are
you comfortable when somebody gets in on
a single on you like do you do you have
any form of panic at all you're like no
this is when the wrestling starts yeah i
don't care yeah that's why i do i have
so much panic and somebody touches my
body dude like if somebody's like this
oh dude i
get off me i freaking panic i like it i
remember when pat down he was training
with us down there and uh
and he goes
he goes he's like he's like i will let
anybody grab my leg he's like because
he's like it doesn't even start
wrestling until they touch it until they
touch on me you see my ears i don't have
any cauliflower yeah because i'm a
defensive wrestler so they shoot it on
my legs then i defense and then i go
around and i end up taking them down so
i was primarily a defensive wrestler
and so you welcomed it that's how you
feel that's a high score like i want
people to try to take me down
dude that gives me so much anxiety
starting wrestling trying to transition
from kickboxing
that's weird don't fall down like
in my
in my 26 professional fights in my 26th
fight i was still like that
if you smelled at me wrong i'd fall
over don't touch me
yeah wrestling is hard no
okay
yeah rose's getting loose well you know
like wrestling yeah wrestling's hard but
mma wrestling is totally different
because timing and the flow yeah and
like if you if you like gsp right i
don't know if gsp is a good wrestler on
his own but mma wrestling wise he had
some of the best timing ever i never
seen somebody who
took so much time to really perfect the
craft
gsp started wrestling just because he
got beat by matt hughes and he was like
never again he joined the canadian
wrestling team
and he worked their way he worked his
way kind of just as like hey guys can
you kind of show me how to wrestle and
he worked himself so good that he was
even thinking about competing
for the wrestling team
yeah like he started off and just says
okay show me how to do to show me how to
do that just simple takedowns and he got
so good by the end of it he was
competing with their best wrestlers who
were competing on the world stage that's
how good gsp wrestling was
hey man i understand that gsp is a good
dude but is there anything we can do
about his hair
his hair the blonde yeah
he looks like
he looks like he's confused between
being a superman and like uh like a bond
villain
but is it is this i don't think it's
blind anymore i think he changed it up
is
he did like a floor he did like a yeah
like the bleach blind yeah like a frosty
like when you squeeze lemon in your hair
and it gets something but you know what
i don't blame him for that you know why
because he was in south florida a lot
and that's like
he was man that's like south florida man
like
see look at south florida see look boom
look at him
look at him you see he's got he's got
his florida shirt on his hair all iced
out lightly it might be the sun doing
that see it might be disgusting
yo you're a dick dude that's the sun do
that to his hair
that's the sun yo that's the sun bro
that's the sound cause it's only on the
top
not the sun bruh let me tell you
something if son did that to somebody's
hair they would stop they'd wear a hat
nah that's the sun man i think it might
be the same
[Laughter]
i like you said it for george i like
that no you know i think i think it
might be how like michael jackson
like his hair was naturally turned that
color so he just blonde bleached the
tips of it to make it go all the way
like that you know who we're talking
about um bleaching when uh your boy
scotty jorgenson got all those crazy
tattoos because he had vitilago and the
vitiligo he knew was gonna bleach his
skin so he was like [ __ ] it so he got
all those crazy vibrant colored tattoos
and by the time the villago stripped
them down his tattoos looked like
like damn blacklight tattoos
you ever seen this nine i've seen it
pull up scotty jorgensen um j-o-r-g-e-n
oh yeah yeah yeah jorgensen jordan yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and the way he did yeah
um like he got all these tattoos and
because he knew he had vitiligo so he's
gonna be losing his
you know that um vitilago is like when
you have like a pigmentation disease and
it makes your pigmentation like come in
in some spots and not in others so you
have like really blotchy blotchy skin
yeah like for me it'll like turn
my skin like white in patches you know
that's what i said michael jackson had
yeah and that's when he started getting
really crazy and bleaching the skin out
i didn't know that was that like that's
scotty scotty there
and so he had it and then sooner or
later he went that's him when everything
went stripped
but look how crazy his tattoos look
yeah they look nice man dude that's like
that's a good billboard for what you
want tattoos to look like yeah
yeah perfect scan for the tattoo huh
and that crazy man like hi death hey
talking about i didn't realize it was
like an ongoing thing i thought that
those people who look like that they
said physical contact and exertion makes
it worse so it makes it makes it
expedite hey how about this you're going
to talk about crazy color changes
like that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah well
dusty yeah she's beautiful man
but it almost looks as if like makeup
man yeah it looks like it's makeup don't
it good for her
yeah lexie i wonder if i wonder if she's
trying to stop that uh the the spread of
that or ah she like it she embraces it
man
she got like dials and everything was
like like ever evolving thing i know
that she was just born like that but
eventually it was tripped down won't it
i don't know her's like i don't know
what she got i thought it did um and do
they have to be careful their skin like
that like an albino because it's if it
pulls the pigment out right do we have
to be worried about that i don't even
know to be honest but i don't mind that
picture though though it looks amazing
yeah i mean i look at that uh hey you
want to talk about crazy uh skin colors
though but it makes you think different
about the skin color think about it
because she's tech she's black and white
there you go rose get up there you go
yeah also like
neither look in that weird like look
right in the middle of her body she has
two circles yeah like in that wild man
yeah god the body's crazy dude
hey pull up sammy sosa then and now oh
boo okay you'll see okay have you seen
sammy sosa oh yeah
have you seen him yeah yeah bruh sammy
sosa just wait just wait
oh man that's not right what
yeah man that's sammy sosa sammy salsa
look
he's like yeah man yeah did that or
that's that's good not us he did that
he yeah he's pushing the skin bleaching
product
how crazy is that huh
sammy it works that's what happens when
you have too much money
i mean
the product works
actually i think he should probably know
that his that he's not a warm palette
guy he's probably got to switch a cold
palette oh
i know you're talking about
pink's i did this fight anyways rose is
heating up though
oh see it's heating up though the fight
is heating up
they starting to open up a little bit
third round
i have not paid attention to this fight
whatsoever
same
yeah
i'm gonna wish i could say something
well they just fainted at each other for
the first year
put a whole lot you missed it right
rose looks like she has really good uh
uh take down defense she flares out
really well in that oh on that wizard
yeah
but she's got to start taking some
chances
if you're gonna go if you're on the road
and you gotta eat something
do you get a jimmy john do you get a
subway what do you get
i get an apple
do you
you don't need like like if you don't
like a vegetarian sandwich
yeah
no that's some fruit so the thing the
thing about it is the fact that like
i'll i'll do i'll do better
off of eating fruit than i would
vegetables because with the fruit
it doesn't have everything that the
sugars and everything that my body is
going to be craving but the fruit does
so when it comes to like giving me that
like that feeling of i have something in
my body and i'm not hungry
a fruit would take care of that because
of the sugar in it
really like eating candy and if so as i
say so if you eat vegetables you're
going to find yourself eating candy
later on well if i eat some vegetables
i'm going to find myself really feeling
hungry because it's going to be like
dude you're still craving something yeah
i'm craving the sugars
you know
that's interesting
do i i don't think i i hardly ever eat
fruit how long do your fight career was
before you changed to vegetarian
oh it was i was like towards i was like
pretty much done like i wasn't i wasn't
a vegetarian until like i came back to
fighting oh okay yeah like but when i
was in it i was
eating whatever i had a terrible diet
when i was fighting what was it that
really made you make the switch
ah mushroom trip really yeah man oh
we're gonna talk about umbro man
about humble yeah
huh yeah i wanna talk about that i want
to talk about how you got into it
so uh i need to order some of your stuff
i was gonna go on the online yeah so
humble is a company that
myself uh
dale jolly who was part of d crim denver
and like just like one of the
coolest dudes that uh
that i know
and jake
plummer you know jake the snake plumber
the quarterback for the cardinals for
the cardinals yep and for the broncos
so we uh you know we started a
functional mushroom company
and the functional mushroom company you
know we sell lion's mane turkey tail and
reishi and we have it in a couple
different modalities you know we have it
in a bar like if you have our bar
it's it's one of the best bars you'll
probably ever have like a snack bar and
then we have these capsules michael rise
and michael rest michael rise is like a
like a pre-workout and when you feel it
it's mushrooms you feel it you just like
it feel like a pre-workout but it don't
give you that jittery feeling it's just
like a nice clean burn you know how it
is when you do it's like chaga and uh
what's in the
what's in the mushrooms
what's that this is the mushroom that we
did what kind of mushrooms are there we
have uh lion's mane
turkey tail
um and then we have um
rhodiola and uh
yeah
but it but it's just
like when you take it you just like
not jittery but just like a smooth
steady progression of just like
really you know
really good energy but
well
yeah man but yeah man so we said we
started a company like a few years ago
and which now just get to the point
where we're like launching it you know
like we're actually coming out you know
like building a company up and getting
all the pieces in order and we just like
did our launch and now we're still like
you know we're like in like 60 stores
right now was there a concept like that
before are you guys novel
nah like there's there's mushroom
companies out there there's a lot of
mushrooms like mushroom bars and stuff
like that yeah like mushroom mushroom is
uh
like the mushroom space is growing so
much like because mushrooms are like how
cbd was you know what i'm saying back in
the day like people are starting to
understand like the benefits of what
functional mushrooms can do not only
silicon which is what functional
mushrooms can do for neurological health
you know i'm saying like functional
mushrooms are the best when it comes to
neurological health
and people starting to understand that
so a lot of companies are starting to go
to functional mushrooms
you see like that that mud water and all
that you know the
yeah so i mean people starting to get it
dude i feel
i need to be better about stuff like
that because like i don't
i don't eat my i don't like mushrooms i
don't eat mushrooms unless i'm gonna
trip like that's it like but i don't
like the texture of cooked mushrooms
like i feel like they get slimy and kind
of weird but you know what though and
that freaks me out i don't either but
these are the were made right now these
are bomb yeah but you know you know what
mushrooms you gotta have though what's
that you gotta have lion's mane lion's
mane yeah lion's mane listen did i
remember here those are like aren't they
like memories supported or something
like that yeah yeah oh wow wow look at
this it's a big moment this is a huge
moment oh [ __ ] it's a huge moment oh oh
[ __ ]
swim out of there oh
whoo that was a huge moment
oh boy rose really doesn't want to scrap
with her huh she wants to have distance
yeah she ain't trying to get on the
ground with her at all jab switch kick
yep but lion's mane tastes like lobster
straight up shut up swear to god bro it
tastes like lobster jake plummer has
like this farm it's called uh michael
farms
and they send you this like lion's mane
you can package it and you can they'll
send it to you and it's absolutely
amazing it's so good
but uh
you know you put it on the grill you
grill it and it tastes just like lobster
meat man just like lobster meat yeah i'm
amazing i had um in indiana they go
morel hunting all the time the morale is
everywhere there that's the only kind of
mushroom to ever hear about
yo go on for it's like lobster for
people to eat meat or is that like a
vegetarian thing no no no no it tastes
like lettuce no
i never had lobster before okay i never
had it before but the people who have
had lots of people you've never had
lobster no i can't have
yeah yeah i'm allergic to it
um hey you wanna know i went to a dinner
uh and i had some it was in l.a so i'm
really fancy with the military
executives
and we had wagyu
and it was the most tender
something i've ever tasted in my entire
life i never thought
i never thought i could taste something
like that
i had it with gsp in hollywood at boa i
think in
l.a the only time i ever had it was with
gsp he was like try this
all right i got you i got it
yeah they'd be having some crazy steaks
out in uh
in uh new york city the age stakes
that's like
100 for a steak
do i no matter how much money i've made
in my life i still see something like
that i'm like [ __ ] that yeah right like
that still gives me that's like the cows
they massage and give yeah
yeah yeah
come on carla but she wants that real
bad yo carla's no joke man
look at this let's go good job rose
oh my god
one on the kisser on the way up
one on a kisser
well she wants that one real bad she
does man
um
what would you tell them about
i need that happy hungry hippo
but
wagyu
paying too much for it no matter how
much money you have oh that's right yeah
right
it goes yeah it kind of looks like a
young girl yeah i'm excited about that
right there man beholves versus wreckage
next week i'm gonna be there yeah yeah
yeah what's your schedule with that like
how about this just just whenever like
maybe at least once a month sometimes
twice a month but yeah yeah that's on
your it's on your schedule yeah pretty
much yeah but there's so many analysts
that they switch through you know yeah
yeah
it's good man but that's like the fifth
or sixth time she slipped on that floor
please get her feet wet
yeah
um it's good i remember because a long
time they didn't use former fighters to
be analysts they use other people so i'm
glad they've changed that up like that's
all they do now yeah yeah well they
should right
it's it's a career path we're built for
if you know how to talk well i mean
that's what they do on other sports and
like football and everything like that
and
you know we bring a perspective that
the credibility yeah credibility and
just perspective that you you get you
know you got to live it you know that
so
they get it they understand it and it's
also a good look for the sport to have
well-spoken fighters that aren't you
know right the stereotypical clinton is
the only one
yeah
hey so rose is winning the fight but
it's not by a landslide a lot because
nobody's done anything in this fight
except
she's played very dif
excuse me very defensively
but um
she's his asparagus
she's not she's not busy enough with
that lead that lead hand you know i'm
saying she's faking it but she's not
touching her enough with it if she was
touching enough with it then she'll be
able to follow up with some other things
but she's not she's not touching with
that lead hand enough
well because she's not touching her
though because she's trying to keep
distance stay away from that shot
like rose has good take down the fence
but
she's obviously paranoid about that shot
otherwise she'd be trying to touch her
up a little bit more yeah
but damn we're in a fight though you
know you gotta hit somebody got
somebody's gotta touch somebody so let's
touch somebody
it's kind of the point but y'all kind of
hang time you're trying to get over
there i don't know it's coming it's
going i don't even know yeah he's just
doing his own thing oh i forgot we're in
that locker room in here i forgot
i forget sometimes i say something and
they're like what does that mean
i forgot my phone man
the hang time you're gonna be like that
you're gonna be like miami-dade pretty
soon you know whenever you guys move to
miami i was like man everybody got locks
out here like everybody's dressed
next thing you know i'm like you know
what
let me try these out yeah man i even
went through the ugly stage but i
remember what i had like the little rat
titties oh they weren't very good i
remember seeing them like oh [ __ ] what
are you doing what are you doing but it
just really
yo it coincided so much in my life man
you know i was going through that that
period in my life you know
that's that's how you got to get them
though it comes with knowledge yeah you
got all the experiences wisdom you know
you earned those man this dude really
out here rocking the whole
oh
anthony anderson i remember he had the
answer
he gave me courage i could do mine
[Laughter]
oh that might be the best punch of the
fight is the best punch that's the
highlight right there is it
this is close man
oh
bro's had a good combination though
going for that liver to come up top but
then then uh
carlos definitely won that guy oh for
sure for sure but i'm saying there's a
good combination that rose through and
she's got stuck in the middle of it
i'm surprised how well that carlos
like standing up with her you know
like this the area where i thought she
would be completely overwhelmed
but it's part of the reason why
like
her wrestling is still a threat
rose hasn't put her enough on her back
foot a wrestler can't take a shot on his
back foot a wrestler needs to be moving
forward and that's the whole problem in
this game is that rose is is going but
she's not going enough to make her get
on that back she doesn't want to commit
and step forward yeah she's doing it
scares me man because because you for
you to put pressure on a wrestler to
make them go on their back foot means
all you're doing is making it easier for
them to snatch up your leg you're doing
ultimately what they want that's going
forward that's it
like and then all their weightness will
use it for you to try to touch them up a
little bit but that's what that's it but
that's
pregnant but they only get that if you
overextend so if you go for punches that
overextend then they look for that
because they can just push up and go
underneath but if you go for center mass
like if you punch for the chest then
that's what a wrestler hates because
you're taking the center
and everything and if you show them the
center and you go right for the center
it's hard for him to like
oh that's good over here why does it
look like rosie wearing blush
because she got called that left hook
there's a massage right
i love the way rose is moving on she's
moving so good
well that her movement is definitely
throwing off carla's shot yeah for sure
he's throwing off her shot but i feel
like there needs to be more off the
movement
there you go like do something right
there
one row shaved her head and she's like
you know what i'm tired of being totally
i'd be pretty oh there you go there you
go it's right there it's been years it's
been years yeah yeah and she was like
[ __ ] it she had long hair too and just
shaved it all off like how do you like
me now
i like how big my dick is
[ __ ] rose i love her
i don't remember what she looked like
before but i remember like right when
she did it i was like oh she's really
hot
yeah
right all of a sudden she did it i was
like oh she's hot
yeah it is the angles are sick man
because those angles they're traps you
know what i'm saying they're not only
angles to get away the traps
yeah rosa's definitely went
uncomfortably but
this is a tough fight
both of them are gonna be tagged from
cardio yeah
like their calves are gonna be sore
like look see roses sliding both of them
slip yeah
they should be putting water on the
ground
maybe that's why rosie's very aggressive
it's changed that much since when you
were when you guys first came to the ufc
yeah i feel like now it's like almost
like supposed to be like sandpaper well
so i mean i i think i think the canvas
is still the same but
you never know what they span on these
mats before in between because they kind
of disinfect everything since the whole
culvert thing so they come through and
they spray the mats
with something to clean the mats in
between
you know bellator fights that it felt
like i was standing on like skateboard
like grip tape like like super grippy
like you can just all cut up from it
afterwards nice roll roll nice rolls we
could have been got that
look at y'all
that was
really really dull
i mean
that was just really dull godly
hey man i'm gonna be hey guys good job
we just talked our way through a
30-minute [ __ ] fight
i'm really proud of you guys for for
enduring what we just did hey that was
like that we just fought our way through
a bad trip that's what we just did i'm
really proud of you guys hey it's only
sunshine on the other side i love you
guys good job i feel like we just went
to war good job guys
you're really proud of us
she stuffed her right there yeah she did
she started to get up she said no [ __ ]
but i mean that was kind of the story of
the fight though it just kind of rose
just waiting for that takedown that
that carlos
i haven't watched a lot of carlos fights
but i feel like a lot of them end up
being that way that's slower but she
can't really quite get going she doesn't
well when she does it she get like when
she goes she goes like it when carla is
getting those take downs landing she
gets tenacious on top you see how fast
she transitions to yeah
oh yeah
she climbed quick
i think i think chico's rose's uh
training partner isn't he yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's crazy huh man that chicks have to
train with dudes because there's so few
that have
the the capability of where they are
like dude the first time i seen
uh
amanda nunez
she came to the gym
and i had no idea like
who she was or nothing like that right
so like i see this girl over there
training
and she was in the corner
just trimming dudes like trimming them
like i'm like yo who like it was
noticeable like yo who was this she was
just
giving it to sticking and moving
she was doing her thing i'm just like
[ __ ]
i'm like yo she's nasty here man give me
the anxiety hearing that yeah she she
was nasty man you know hey man there was
this chick
named tatsuka kacha the six foot five
chick who's trained with us down another
oh good gosh [ __ ] the girl girl she was
hot she was pretty six or five yeah she
was [ __ ] pretty ass chick really she
[ __ ] me up dude because i'm like i'm
like am i am i lying at all nah nah she
got me one day too
yeah yeah yeah oh my god carla what
wow
we weren't paying attention yeah holy
well neither were the judges or anybody
else in the crowd
or the audience
wow wow
we were not paying attention no
well i don't really know what to say
about that i don't know if i'm shocked
i'm not i'm not i'm not believing this
though like i don't i don't think that
she won the fight
i mean she had she had great pressure
she did land some shots
but
she's she's two and overs rose huh yeah
i mean yeah
well anyway so gotcha six foot five yeah
so this chick
is a pretty chick from russia wherever
she's from
and she comes in and she's like
she's like um
sparring with dudes right she's a big
chick she's probably 665
six five two forty and pretty good
pretty all day long
and uh comes in this pretty 240 pound
girl you wanna pull her up you everyone
on the ground yeah i got a little grab
hey she's bad yo she beat my ass dude
like i was like trying to be cool as a
chick but i'm not trying to dot her in
the face
she kicked me so hard in the head she
does this like rainbow kick she caught
you with a rainbow kick yep
she cut me this rainbow kick
dude i swear i buckled like it's the
only time in my life i've been like
buckled like that and i was like my
baby's not gonna be real oh dude i swear
to god and she and she's not cool at all
no i mean she's cool but like in
practice she's not cool yo
i was doing it like okay
i'm going with the girl i hadn't really
been in a while i don't really i didn't
really know that she was that dope so i
was like yeah i'm going with the girl
you know and i was like trying to like
not warm up around yeah not not be that
dude you know
she threw a kick and it was like
you know you feel that [ __ ] i was like
yo i had to fight it for real man
i had to fight it for real man i don't
know where you're getting knocked out
but no man i had to fight it for real
though
on my post on my grandma pulled up
she kicked me so hard
look how tall she is she kicked me so
hard look at her ig and see and see her
doing like some some kicks and stuff she
does everybody like that she everybody
kick it is a specialty yeah she kicked
me so hard i was like you know what [ __ ]
her i'm open her ass so all i did was
drop low kick after low kick at the low
i tried to break her legs that day
like yeah and then i caught up with a
jab and i thought i broke her spine i
was like well you know what shouldn't
have done that to me
guys
we have one more quick message from
brandon let's take a look let's enjoy
the gringo poppy
i'm back what's up baby i'm not there
actually but here i am good to see you
guys once again
we're just a couple dads man tough 10
alumni look at us sitting around this
table drinking having fun watching the
fights who would have thought man
we're all a lot thicker except for
rashad because you're vegan or eating
plants whatever that's cool man uh keep
doing you dude but listen as dads
you all can relate to this man we uh we
care about our lawns i'll tell you what
where i live if you have a bad lawn dude
you're getting roasted they're talking
about you at the the hoa meetings
they're they're making fun of it you
need a green lawn man i'm gonna give you
guys a little secret you fella fellow
dads out there you need a green lawn you
know how my lawn's freaking so green my
ficuses look like jumanji son that's
right everyone's like yo how's he do it
well here's the secret this is only for
the four of you
and the millions of listeners watching
right now and viewers
it's called sunday all right because
spring's almost here all right we're so
close to feeling that soft grass under
our feet but first we need to get our
lawn back it has to be green man
thankfully my friends at sunday get your
lawn grown and helps keep it healthy all
season long if you've got a brown lawn
you're a bad dad let's be honest you're
not you're not doing what it takes man
to keep it green kids love green lawn
science look it up all right
you gotta get on it man sunday can help
you grow a beautiful lawn without the
guesswork or the nasty chemicals all
right okay you want your kids running on
chemicals you want your dog that little
soft wet nose all up in the grass with
chemicals come on man
we don't want any of that man that's
where sunday has custom plans all right
they include fertilizer everything you
need to easily care for your lawn with
ingredients like seaweed iron molasses
you can feel good with the kids and pets
being around on that lawn with sunday
all you have to do is visit
getsunday.com
put in your address all right their lawn
experts do the rest they use soil and
climate data to create a personal
nutrient plan delivered to your door
when you need it and this is the best
part you just attach it when it comes
all right it's a ready-to-use pouch and
then you put on your freaking garden
hose you spray away takes your boy 15
minutes and then i'm bragging all summer
long all spring lawn check out the green
oh my god your lawn brendan oh my god i
i know it's sunday i wish you could say
it was me but it's sunday all right best
of all this stuff really works and
sunday is offering you guys 20 off
yeah rashad 20 off dude
full season plans are just 129 bucks and
you can get 20 off at checkout when you
visit getsunday.com
that's 20 off your custom plan at
getsunday.com
shop now let's get back to the program
take it away fellas don't touch my
whiskey
what it do beautiful people what it do
it's me and my man rashad joe's over
there i'm trying to pull down the heater
going p or something so we're gonna hold
it down for the pain
hey i try i'm a professional snitch hey
if you're not on mike and time let's get
on the mic i'm gonna throw heat at you
i'm gonna let you know
i'm straight shade all day long
that's all right though that's all right
i'm i'm a little thrown off by that rose
fight i don't think anybody won that
fight but i don't think rose lost it
yeah that was that was tough man i mean
i didn't i didn't see any point in a
fight where
i thought
excuse me carla had control
you know i didn't see it
um
yeah
but i mean i mean she fought a great
fight though you know what i'm saying
she fought she fought the perfect fight
because
she took somebody who was a great
stand-up fighter
and just totally made her
you know second guess herself not really
throw combinations not be able to throw
combinations all based on the fact that
she was worried about getting taken down
so when you're able to do that to
somebody's game you're effectively
imposing your will without even imposing
your will yeah yeah yeah you're right i
mean you she changed rose because rose
is so concerned about that that
potential shot yeah i mean you're
absolutely right about it yeah she
changed the whole game yeah
i can't i mean it's a really solid point
i want to argue with you because i think
the fight just sucked but like like i
can't argue with whether you're what
you're saying yeah it's
it wasn't it was it wasn't fun to watch
but i mean that's the thing about when
you get rematches sometimes you either
get like one of those fights where it
pick up where
you know like the the fifth or the third
round or the fourth round where you know
they wish you had more time when it was
heating up or you get like a dud and
i get it yeah i get it
i get it dude i'll be on this another
one too i've never been a charles
oliveira fan
no i just i just can't no let me ask you
what do you think that this
losing a belt on a scale
does a charles oliveira going into this
fight
i mean does he fight
what character too emotionally hot
okay
i don't see cool calm collected i see
that if you missed weight as a champion
your head's not in the right spot
you you have you're eating too good
you're too many people are telling you
you're this you're that
something is going wrong in your life
where you let your leg astray and you
let yourself be led astray
if you're a champ like but then again
half a pound jim was over here saying
earlier well hey what's the matter it
doesn't matter you're a champion like i
think i feel like a lot but they also
said that the scales of the at the joint
were screwed up they said that that's
right
that's what some fighters are saying the
hotel half pound seems like something
sketched and like yeah you missed weight
by five pounds but they give you
something wrong with you you're not
trying but then they give you time to go
get get that half pound off you can't
get extra time get your pot you half
pound off that's a huge problem that's
not anybody else
yeah that's that's the part right there
is like
the fact that he was
already so drained
to even get on the scale and then to
have that 0.5
that's the worst news in the world you
know what happened to me one time i was
cutting weight and i thought i did an
amazing job i was cutting early i was
going to be nice
and and done early right so i finished
before keith jardine did we we were
fighting the same car
and greg was like listen go hang out in
the room and just relax till we get back
like nah i'll wait for you guys on here
i'll be a team player he said all right
cool just don't jump in the pool
i was like why he said don't jump in the
pool you'll gain a weight back i'm like
nah no way no way
so low and behold i didn't believe him i
jumped in the pool
i gained a pound and a half bro
because your body picked it back up
because all your uh your pores are over
so you think your body just your body
just sucks and it's chlorine too huh so
it wasn't easy to get rid of that it
wasn't it was hard i was crying i was
crying i was in a waiting fresh room but
crying greg was like see i told you i
told you you wanted to laugh you thought
it was a joke
i don't want to do this
dude i gotta so so i would say i was a
heavyweight i never had to cut weight
didn't have to worry about it right i'm
at ufc 100 we just got out of the
ultimate fighter and um
jake o'brien was fighting jon jones i
think
jacob was fighting jon jones i was there
with jake o'brien and i had to stand in
the um
and the sauna with him because he wasn't
going to stand there and it was full it
was full like that's first time i've
ever met dan henderson i know any of
these people i just got through to my
fighter just got off didn't know
anything about what was going on
and i see this old man standing outside
like there was this glass door for the
sauna right and i had to crack just a
little bit so i could get some cold air
because i was really unhappy in there
yeah
and i'm looking out i bet you're right
and there's this old man
bald headed loose skin looks like hell
standing there butt ass naked dick
swinging in the breeze has it has no
problem out there just [ __ ] naked as
the day is long with a towel around his
shoulders holding on to it and i'm like
who the [ __ ] is this guy i know like
that's mark coleman sir
what dude like who's mark coleman and
they're like uh this who and i was like
that's who that guy is absolutely that
dude did not give a single [ __ ] about
being badass naked in front of the whole
world
so then so i'm in there right now i'm
laughing about mark omar i think this
dude is absolutely nuts so i'm not
laughing about that you know when dan
henderson's in there and he's like he's
like
he's like [ __ ] coleman he's like i'm
surprised he's not out there just trying
to rub one out or some [ __ ] you know and
he's in there and co and he's in his
full sauna suit whatever else and uh
cb dollarways in there by the way do you
know what cb stands for
cb
what his name it's initials um do you
know what sand is
no idea charles bronson
so anyway so cb's in there and he's got
i think he's got like boxing gloves on
or something like that and he's in there
and he's like you know his voice you
know it's all kind of like this he's
like ah so hot i can't take it anymore
it's gone dying it was a hot ass hot tub
or whatever i mean hot sauna and uh dan
henderson's like you [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
like aren't you a wrestler and uh cb's
like yeah i am and they like dan like
starts pulling off a sauna which has
like two sweatsuits underneath the sauna
suit has his like pants tight rolled
three pairs of socks on like takes all
the stuff off and he's like he's like
dude [ __ ] stop and i was like who's
that guy
that's [ __ ] dan
ultra ultra alpha dude and he's so chill
too yeah cool as [ __ ] he's so chill
he's training team quest back in the day
and a little bit [ __ ] has the
hardest bones i've ever felt in the
world he just feels like they're he's
dense as hell right why is he so dense
right he like bumps into you and hurts
you
hey did y'all all right shot i know you
know this story and i want you to fill
me in on it
i need to hear the story about his fake
tooth
who dan henderson yeah
you don't know this i don't know do you
know the story
okay so i'm gonna speak a little bit out
of turn because i believe i know this
story but i was told
that
him and randy were sparring and they
were working doing whatever
and um
he did something to randy like slammed
him or something like too hard and randy
was like
i bet so like they like
all right we're good
like they just they're like [ __ ]
homies they squirt each other up that's
it just blast it that's it just
dot them up pop it shoot that was like
all right we good now all right that's
the old school [ __ ] right there that was
cool
you guys know the canelo box today i
guess pavoli yeah yeah apparently he
lost no way out boxed him yeah no no
i thought about that man everybody was
asking me about the fight and i was like
i don't want to watch the fight i
already know who's going to win i'll
watch the highlights it's kind of crazy
so for him to win i wonder what the
biggest bet was on on on on bavoli
that's what i want to know
um do you think he'd do it
i mean i'm not saying he would but i
mean listen i'm just saying the judges
so there's a meme so canelo's minus 550
favorite
ooh so vivoli was what probably a plus
400
plus 400 to me that's
minus 550 to a plus 400 doesn't really
seem like that much of a good bet
like i put 100 hours on
the chick that fought kayla harrison
yesterday
i put 100 on her because she was plus 3
000.
like that's what i would expect against
canelo i don't know if you put 500 on
bevel you made a pretty [ __ ] wow
wow that's incredible
wow absolutely wow um okay so let's talk
about this for a minute uh lomachenko
is he is he really that good or has he
had just not had any real talent or
competition to be tested by he's not the
champion no more he lost he lost
to timothy my lopez yeah to female lopez
lopez
like he's the new guy and he just lost i
mean he lost the camp it all changes
when these guys actually start fighting
each other yeah the boxers they always
like they always like dance around each
other and then all of a sudden how did
lomachenko lose
yeah i mean um
that fight yeah he was just that's not a
good portrait not not appointed but i
mean he just
yeah
he got beat he got beat he got beat he
got beat
[Music]
they all died their hair that's like a
that's a dude outfit right there
all right so there's a meme yesterday i
shared it shaw doesn't doesn't agree
with this thing
but say
uh
say potentially the ufc told uh
oliveira
miss wait and your next fight will be
the connor fight for the thing miss way
to win the fight
we'll strip you from the title now the
title's vacant conor can come in for the
155 title shot
why
mom there's no way they there's no way
they could give tony connor a title shot
absolutely no chance he hasn't been i
wouldn't say no chance he hasn't he
hasn't won he hasn't won in five years
or four years something like that he
hasn't spoken in two years
but what's he what you see the thing
about this though the champ can choose
to fight who he wants to fight
you know what i'm saying so it always
can be like the champ is conor's calling
out the championship all right i want to
fight conor you know that's true
that already happened before yeah yeah i
mean
i guess
yeah
i guess i just don't understand how that
uh how that
who's still an enamored by conor i just
i don't get it
like yeah i mean
where is it where's the excitement at
with connor
my needle's not moving
connor i mean i'm just not it's it's
but here's the thing about it is it is a
circus
it's all those different things but
there is still something
very appealing about watching
connor fight because you know
something's gonna happen like either he
has that seething moment that he had in
his last fight when he fought against uh
uh dustin poirier when he was just
talking that crazy [ __ ] at the end of
the fight that was cloud that was a
classic moment you know what i'm saying
that was a classic i don't agree with
the show i don't agree with it but it's
like it was it was a classic connor
moment you know and you get used to
seeing this guy get you seeing like you
know what this is going to be another
moment so
i don't know i feel like
for him though like he's in a position
where
he's gotta tap back into that dog
in that mentality but it's so hard
because he's so far removed from that
mentality
that's not rocky apollo creed i'll do it
tomorrow there is no tomorrow
that's that moment like hey man if you
don't have if you don't if you're rocky
which he is now right like he's he's
rocky what's that four
yeah he's rocky four now
so if he's like four he needs to he
needs to try to go back to find an
apollo creed no i don't know if he can i
think he's ostracized himself so much
that he doesn't have access to an
apartment so he needs to find an apollo
creed he needs to find an apollo
creature he does who who is it who's
that apollo creep
i'm sure there's some young hungry buck
but there's got to be somebody that can
look because he's not going to respect
some young hungry book because somebody
gets out on the videos will get leaked
right right so there's so who what do
you do
who who could you possibly trust to be
your apollo creed right somebody that's
going to push them up somebody who's
going to be and get on them get get in
that ass yeah
like that's a tough spot
and on top of that you have to do you
have to
rent the damn warehouse and be secluded
because everybody's gonna try to just
everything the whole the whole thing no
you're right though
he's because he's got to do that kind of
like overall reconstruction of his game
and does he want it the dude's got a lot
of money right now why does he want to
do it why does he want to do it because
it's something that he can't do right
now and that's connor if there's
something that he can't do he wants to
do i can i can't argue that
but i mean
that is an awesome part of the movie
though
you know what i'm saying
there is no tomorrow
that [ __ ] is intense
you know carl weathers played
professional football
did he he sure did
that that dude had the body though
remember remember those guns bro he was
acting jackson two jackson jackson yo
people forget about access jackson man
action jackson was a good film man
that uh what was it fast faster and
faster
predator oh man yeah he went hard and
president
yeah
every time with arnold the
the shake hands and they got the arms
yeah the arms
but it didn't count though they did they
did a movie thing like the uh the
ultimate warrior right the uh the strap
around the bicep
i think out
so we got here you guys think that
oliveira is
missing a step because he missed weight
oh man um
i don't think his mind's in the right
spot man
i mean i feel like if if it was in a
right spot i feel like missing weight is
kind of push it even further
off kilter right because because now
he's in a position where he's fighting
to prove something
and uh fighting from that position
can make you take risks that
don't work out for you and messing with
a guy like him yeah i don't know why i
just got i got a feeling that he's going
to do it but you think you think
i'm a way bigger get you man i just have
a feeling
that uh dude i'll be honest man oh man i
mean it's been a crazy night of fight so
i wouldn't be surprised if oliveira
pulls out
even though i think his head's in the
wrong wrong spot either wouldn't be
surprising he pulls it off i won't be
surprised either man but i'm i'm praying
for gaichi man i'm hoping okay
family's on the line who do you say
justin gets you you
joe
uh
family's on the line
so you got to make a call
i mean oh my i already got him uh i
think i already called it nah that's
been justin getting warmed up
oh gosh
that's a lot of pressure quick
just hitting i mean he's coming forward
yeah
dang
he's eating that dang this guy's like a
bad dream
i'm surprised he's giving justin that
space i thought he's gonna keep
pressuring him nah he's got that front
kick he want that's he's oh got him
again
oh
he got it i changed my boat you better
better not jump on top of him
look at him he got back up this is what
they needed after that after that that
last rose fight yeah for real
oh my god
getting hit oh that was a delay that was
a delay yeah oh that one hurt
oh my god guys look at that naught on
his head see this is why i love [ __ ] oh
my god my
i'm so excited right now that over here
and right is coming in so clean i wonder
if he makes his whole
hair like that slinging oh my god oh
that left hook could have killed
somebody
oh
the uppercut the uppercut he's looking
for the uppercut oh underneath who's
going for that choke
that's going back to aloe vera
that's gotta be so let's go for him for
for gate didn't know that he
he's catching them with though
the overhang right on the break
is lethal look see he's gonna go for a
choker
oh
good job justin good job dude there he's
so he's so good in a lot of places man
yo justin gates he kicked so hard man
everybody just tells me like yo this
dude kicks your leg even in training
with them he wanted to shoot him so bad
you see that and was like yeah nope
because the leg kicks are crazy
oh god
gosh this is violent go mine
what who fights like that justin bieber
if he goes second round trevor whitman's
going to know he goes
forward right he's going to sue her he
came from p.m trevor is always trying to
slow he was pfl yeah he has pfl oh that
was something yeah he was uh on like a
terrorist bfo right
yeah
catch your breath justin just catch your
breath
i was like
first round oh god uppercut oh my gosh
oh my gosh and he's got the arm trap
that's it oh it's gone
oh yeah that's right i called that [ __ ]
never doubted my mom wow
jesus criminy wow
i would like to go on the record and say
my family is safe
[Music]
let you guys know
hey dude he has so much pressure god
dang he is all really on a roll right
now that [ __ ] was so good
though it was so sweet sick fight
justin's a man too though i mean that
was funny
dang
he didn't make weight
you didn't make weight
god damn wow
wow that was unbelievable man dude you
know you know what dude
yes
um second uh that is absolutely
incredible that uh that dude had all
that pressure on him and he came out
performing like that how about the
amount of pressure he put on gaithy too
good god
[Music]
god that is dirty
wow
man that was really impressive dude
that dude's on one dude
soldier bro god damn just [ __ ]
terrible you know what he that dude
could not care less he doesn't have a
title right now either he's like who do
you want me to fight next
but it's connor 155.
what'd he endure dude there's no way
connor will not fight that [ __ ]
there's no chance i think
kind of kind of go straight to 170.
that's a monster
god damn
i didn't i thought that dude parades in
the favelas when he got when he won his
title yeah good for him man
okay
i don't want to like him but god dawg
that cat is good man yeah what's not to
like oh man i just i feel like he's so
uh
brash and arrogant and he always was
when like when he first came in but he's
got more bonuses than anybody more
submissions than anybody i guess i kind
of like him but before remember he we
saw him quit in some fights so i thought
that would be a thing yeah
i swear there's a reason right yeah so
that's kind of one of the reasons but i
mean he's he's
gone past that he's
killing now yeah i didn't really i
wasn't paying attention to him but
really no well pay much sense to him to
the last like four fights and i was like
holy [ __ ] it was this guy who the [ __ ]
is this guy yeah dude i mean that's so
nasty bro that dude just is on a go
buddy yeah
and
dude i always find that so gangster when
you push somebody's body off you like
don't touch me yeah right dude you just
i just do you just made you quit get off
don't touch me
like yeah
like on a referee like you he saved your
life the rest of you saved your life
that's a that's a terrible feeling
terrible feeling god i hate losing man
that's the feeling i'd be feeling like
i got choked out in the gym one time and
like if i was like
it bothered me for like weeks like that
guy then i like almost wanted to thank
the guy like you saved my life you
fought that guy yeah where'd you find it
oh the other day when you
[ __ ] and uh the last time yeah they said
that that was tough that he's really
good and they were like a lot of people
were like dude i'm i'm i'm anxious for a
shot
and i was like he'll shadow be just fine
not worried about that
wow
damn what a fight george santiago
what where it's right there to the right
he's with justin gaither right joe
santiago yeah yeah yeah that was
yourself wait
when does that happen
well he transferred tomorrow so he goes
there all the time oh oh that's right
that's right that's right
man that's really
wow dude you're boys that's the dude you
fought and he passed the stairway test
[Laughter]
was he that big when he fought yeah yeah
that dude you fight the heavyweight
pfl uh that dude fought up two or five
two or five yeah that dude right there
yeah
that dude's gonna break any bodily
pieces that the the number of
metabolites in his urine
that [ __ ] will set off a metal detector
that [ __ ] thinks he had a jackpot in
pegasus when he pees in that thing
god yeah buddy
i mean dude that's so impressive
that is so impressive good job man yeah
yeah i i didn't i really didn't see that
man
i did not see that happening he's so
legit you know he was able to like not
get caught up in the emotional part of
it and that was the key you know what
i'm saying like he was still cool calm
and collective
and uh even after getting knocked down
he didn't get panicked he dropped he got
knocked down twice right he got dropped
it was
i think about this too think about this
think about his mentality marked in
there that dude stopped in said hello to
justin
gave every one of his corners dap and
then went over like
like that dude was so casual about
getting rid of the fight he didn't give
a [ __ ] i know though he wowed man he
different
damn there's always that one fight where
you where you see a fighter and then you
gain
new respect for him this is that fight
for me yeah i think it's gonna be i'm
glad i selected it i'm glad my family's
safe thank you guys for keeping my
family proper i appreciate that
hey guys i just wanted to say thank you
very much jason from green mountain
grills you've been super dope thanks for
sponsoring the show thanks for
sponsoring me for as long as you did i
cooked all this buffet this madness i
have a verbal buffet a verbal buffet
that i kick out every damn day but you
let me produce an edible buffet today i
appreciate it beer can chickens we had
meatloaf mom the meatloaf
rashad's vegetables the fruit the
madness i really got to say thank you so
much jason the green mountain girls it's
been a great time um joe's over there
popping this huh his happy hippo uh
herbals everything's been great shots
over here eating everything that's good
for his body and his soul and um i just
got to tell you guys man like it's been
absolutely fantastic it's been a great
experience and we missed brendan
obviously but it was a hell of a go man
guys gentlemen i really appreciate it
boys hey thank you for having us thanks
for having me yeah i appreciate you
having a good time sick fights hey
awesome night man i'm sorry that rose
fight was a little dull but that [ __ ]
was absolute madness everybody thanks so
much for watching hope you guys enjoyed
it and uh otherwise see you when i see
you smile later kids
you